here nope it's not
why can I not find it anymore
[Music]
I said it and leave it
I said it and leave it why can I not
find the mini map
where did it go did they take it out
so here's like your your basic control
stuff I have been kind of playing around
with this right here the camera
Sensitivity I turned it up just a little
bit turned down the aiming Sensitivity I
also found that I prefer the uh camera
acceleration turned down a little bit
aiming acceleration turned down a little
bit as well
oh yeah it's
oh my goodness I promise I've been
playing this game
I've been playing this game
stream gone what
wait hold on can you guys hear me
foreign
oh no
okay
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
what in the world
Ratchet and Clank
what is happening
what is going on tonight too
okay I guess we're switching to Ratchet
and Clank
kidding
I'm totally kidding guys
Andrew broke the stream with his
donation
I'm so lost right now
here's what here's what I want to check
dude
I want to go and see if if I have a
separate live stream showing
in my previous videos I do
oh my gosh you guys
oh this is this is disastrous
this is disastrous I'm not gonna lie
it's like totally broken now my uh
all my analytics it's like on a
completely
separate stream now
looks like your internet dropped and
came back happens to me a lot
but how why did it just completely
it like used a super old title
instead of just popping me right back
into
where I was at
foreign
oh my gosh man all right so here's what
we're gonna do
[Music]
I need I need to be able to update
okay let's go in right here
oh my gosh man
so now like we lost all our viewers
I guess people have to refresh because
they were in the other stream
reset the street yeah right just reset
the stream and start over well I mean I
can fix the
all right so we can fix all the title
that's no problem I just hate losing the
uh
oh man like the way YouTube Works in
terms of all the analytics and
everything like all the so all the
viewers that were in that stream now
like those views aren't gonna count
that's it's gonna treat that as a
completely
separate stream
all right so I'm just gonna update my uh
we're just updating the title and
everything right now get all of that
fixed
Hogwarts Legacy all right and then we
need to change the thumbnail
all right change the thumbnail and Save
cake'd your other stream died had to
wait till this stream popped up like two
minutes later
that is so weird
all right so
now it should be
I don't know how it'll look on mural's
end
and it should um
eventually change to the correct title
because I never lost connection that was
the most bizarre part
I looked over and everything was still
it didn't show me disconnected from the
internet and I just see all these people
saying
that they can't where's retro where's
retro what's happened where's retro
he's gone
now I can't see any of your chat
actually you know what you know what you
know what yes I can yes I can
We're not gonna let this win we're not
gonna let
the obs
God's wind tonight no or demons I should
say
okay
title got you confused at first okay
somebody uh somebody let me know
okay we are criminals I did if you
refresh it if you refresh the Stream
I think it should show the correct title
I think it should show the correct title
now
yeah YouTube's saying excellent
connection
you just lost us all our viewers YouTube
that's what happened everybody that was
watching they're gone they think I'm
done
title change but not the thumbnail yet
okay gotcha
looks great now looks great now okay
never knew reaction Clank was part of
Harry Potter
oh dude
okay
so what I was I was trying to go through
menu items here with you guys
and then all of that started started
happening so
yeah so accessibility options somebody
was saying this is where
where you find it
but no no dude there is there is
somewhere else I have a screenshot for
it actually
hold on
foreign
because it is um
because it was in a different place
it's here it's the last one last one
I was like hold on a second I knew it
was a different one yeah so here's the
one accessibility you can do some things
there
can do some things
but then this one down here is where you
really get into all of the uh
you could just completely hide the mini
map right there
which I recommend doing I recommend
doing
thumbnail is still Ratchet and Clank
oh man it's updated on my end it's
probably just gonna take it a little bit
oh my gosh dude disaster
what a disaster
I've lost all of my um
foreign
Jake what happened I don't know dude
we're still trying to figure it out
thumbnail is fixed too now Draco nice
let's go let's go
looks good here see wolf pack says oh
you're right we are criminals no
oh my goodness we gotta update our our
link
all right
foreign
dude I'm just gonna completely
delete that tweet
all right so
delete
and
okay
it's all right guys it's all right we're
just hanging out we're just hanging out
anyway having a good time waiting as the
as the world slowly comes online getting
to play Hogwarts Legacy here
okay stream died but
her stream died
first stream died but we are not
deterred
back
live with a new link
a brand new link
foreign
that one though
oh there we go perfect
perfect perfect
all right so before everything just died
on us right there
Andrew and a few others we had up a poll
question
asking to who wants to see one
customization
and
it won
the yes vote one
sorry I'm just uh adding the hashtag to
this
all right so
cringe for having map off
cringe trapping map on dude
cringe trapping map on once who wants
that clutter in there cakes let's see
that crispy wooden stick customization
thanks for putting the wands to a poll
the chat Andrew and I have spoken indeed
indeed so we're hanging out here at
hogsmeade uh which I won't spoil oh my
goodness this guy he was in a hurry for
a second I'm not gonna spoil where you
go at the beginning
and how you get your wand initially but
once you do
once you do you have a special option
here in the gear menu everybody's been
wondering how are they going to handle
the wand stuff and this is how they do
it through the wand handles right here
so the wand the core part of it like all
of this right here
you pick that color and you pick that
style
at another time all this right here was
brought over from my Wizarding World
account right here so the beach Phoenix
Feather unbending 12 and a quarter
inches all that's brought over from
Wizarding World
the handles though this right here you
unlock these as you play the game as you
do different quests
so like right here this is one right
here
this one is called the saber Brown wand
handle a sharp Brown handle design
featuring a gold sheath
then this is the one that I've been
rocking with right here just a a very
simple
yet elegant I think an expertly card
wooden handle with a cutting point at
its base
right here we've got a checkerboard teal
one a kingly checkerboard handle design
in black and teal topped with a silver
crown
so I don't I mean you can see I do not
have many so far this one right here
Obby killer
oh orbicular I was like hobby killer how
do you say this an impressive ringed
handle design in Violet so it at least I
haven't discovered yet a way to change
the colors so I think you're just gonna
get different colors
then we have another uh lilac one here
swirl unconventional Twisted handle
design in marbled lilac
he's back is everybody finding it now
yeah yeah we're back we're back we're
back we just had to do a uh
just had to do a little Switcheroo there
streams do not like me tonight OBS is
messing up on me before we even got
started and then uh
then once we were live the stream just
died and moved me it moved me over I
kept streaming but in a completely
different place
I'm going to move these right here to
the middle I think that looks better
guys thank you for all of the let's see
was that L one right there my alerts are
kind of broken by the way
you love how they're selling the wands
yeah like take a look at this I've got
presents take a look at this
so Elwyn had five more gifted congrats
to the gifted members there
and let's see then we had go ninja with
another five dollars currently waiting
in line for my GameStop copy so close oh
my goodness that's awesome so you're
doing like a midnight launch thing huh
how much longer do you have to go go
ninja
because for me I'm on Eastern time so
you would have about three hours to go
yeah congrats to those who got
memberships you guys have the emotes now
so you can spam them can you post them
in the chat there
and you also get a special Discord roll
as well all right so here's the other
one
Imperial brown and gold a stately strong
handle design in burgundy and gold and
then the last one I was rocking this one
for a while avian Brown a marvelous
twisting handle design in light gray
topped with a gold owl
I really like the owl on the bottom of
that one I was using that for a while
but yeah so this all this here you can
bring over from Wizarding World
and then even even when you bring that
over you can still customize
a lot of this this part right right here
so I can't show you that because you you
do that in a different spot
a three hours someone said
9 p.m in New York for release Go Ninja
oh my gosh well you're about to get it
then
New York's Eastern Time
oh yeah we showed the Lilac one did we
skip over this one though
oh yeah swirl Brown unconventional
Twisted handles designed in marbled
Brown
so that's that one right there there's
the Lilac so we got two sort of purple
yeah purple lilac ones but yeah still
quite a few that we don't have unlocked
and
just to show you guys one more thing
here when it comes to
the wands
42.
8 out of 42 collected so if you were
looking at that page and thinking oh
it's kind of disappointing
there's not too many
because let's see I mean you only have
what 4 8 12 16 20
23. you only have 23 here
that's not all
that's not all you can go over this
collections page so only 8 out of 42
here 8 out of 42.
and again this is not really giving
anything away here except some of them
are tied to quests
so you can see there's five tied to the
quest and then all the others
exploration
exploration
Richard with a donation or Super Chat
thank you so much Richard love the
content be playing in three hours count
it down dude count it down
count it down
how are you playing already so I was
fortunate enough that uh WB sent me an
early copy for review
a review yeah it does not have the day
one patch no
does not have the day one patch
what is the no handle option look like
can I even let's see oh wait I think I
can do that yeah
there you go kind of like a drumstick
just the basic
which I'm trying to remember when I
first got it I think this is how when
you first get it I think this is what it
looks like I can't remember if they
automatically get one or not it may
automatically come with one but yeah so
this is the one I've liked so far
although I got I think that one is
pretty cool too
and that one is pretty cool I gotta say
I love what they did with this I love
what they did with this I know people
wanted wand customization so bad that is
something people ask for for so long and
I just I just kept trying to figure out
how is that gonna work within the lore
you know because the wand chooses the
wizard right you're not just supposed to
be able to go around and freely
change up all the wand stuff you know
so that changing out the handle
makes a lot of sense caked yes whenever
we're streaming on Twitch we will we
will have the drops enabled uh it's I'm
pretty sure though the Merlin the Merlin
cloak that everybody wants I think that
one you can only get by
watching their actual Stream So if
you're watching me in the morning I'll
pull it up and I'll remind everybody
make sure you go over there and uh
and do it
but yeah I think you have to be in that
one for it to work
all right so yeah that's that's the wand
stuff guys eight out of 42 that's how
many I have so far
and as far as the other gear goes I
mentioned in the beginning I let my
son's pick my attire so I let them kind
of alternate now if you're looking at
these and you're thinking I don't look
anything
like what these are
let's go over some Pro tips some Pro
tips here things I wish I knew I put a
little list together here
I'm gonna make a video on this too but
this is something that it might take
people a little bit to figure out so I
tried to pick stuff that
I think it's just better if you know
from the beginning so with gear
first off you have a limited number of
slots it's like I'm gonna press on this
gear right here and right now I have 20
out of 28.
you start I think your maximum is only
20.
I think it's only 20 at the start
there is an in-game thing an in-game
activity you can do
to up that number
however
however
basically any gear
that does not have a special trait like
if you look over there in the bottom
right
you see that one has a trait oh yeah and
one other thing I wanted to do
I want to move my
there's really no good place for the oh
there's really no good place for the cam
in this game I thought it might look
better on the other side but
then you guys wouldn't be able to see
that so we'll keep it like this for now
but anything that doesn't have a special
trait so like this one has Ambush on it
increased spell damage while concealed
by disillusionment
but yet the offense it would take me
down so you can see my offense right now
is 147 so it would take it down I don't
want to equip it
or wait that's if I take it off so this
one has the blue so that's what I have
right now
um then if I switch to this one
you could see if I go back here now it's
saying hey if you put that on it will up
that now notice how it changed the
gloves right here
whenever I changed out the attire
however there's a thing in the game this
is how their transmog Works they talked
about this before but they never really
showed it and it's called appearances
so when I hover on this right here you
see if I push Square
I can change out the appearance
so I you can basically sell any gear you
collect as long as you don't want the
trade on it you can sell any gear you
collect and you still keep the
appearance
so all of all of the gloves that I've
found throughout the game they still
show up here in my appearance section
and so I think this is the one
I think that's the one my son had picked
I let them pick
what house will you choose I'm
Gryffindor Landon Gryffindor
so yeah for people asking how we're
playing
um WB sent us an early review copy of
the game so the review is up on the
channel you can check that out
and that's how we're playing yeah we
asked them so can we stream when the
Embargo lifts which was this morning and
they said yep and so yeah that's why
we're that's why we're here streaming it
but yeah I really I like this how you
can sell anything so this this like
weird little hat here
it just happens to be
my best
see how if I put that hat on it's going
to take me down but now watch when I go
back to it I'm it's gonna up me to 158
but then it switches back to the one
that I had set for the appearance
because if I go in here and I push
Square
I can change this appearance to anything
any hat that I've gotten
so like if I wanted to do no hat at all
right there you can do no hat it's
called invisible headwear and yet I
still keep the perk benefit
which is kind of cool now I'm curious to
see how this works as you get higher
level in the game what I really want to
know is is there any reason
like should I basically be hanging on to
these other uh like trait slots so like
this one increase spell damage while
concealed by disillusionment do I want
to try and save where I have multiple
gear pieces of gear that have different
traits or are you eventually going to
hit hit a point where in game you just
have one piece of gear and then all you
have to do is go in and change your
appearance so like right now the cloak
that I'm actually wearing is called the
Twilight cloak right here
so there's what it actually looks like
what the Twilight cloak looks like there
but then if I go here hit Square I can
change the appearance I was rocking this
cape for a while I think that looks
pretty cool too and then here's the dark
arts one
so all of these are
yes Dakota yes that's another good
question yeah good good thing to show
off here so anytime you're wearing a
cloak something that has a hood on it
like this right here if I hover over
this look at that dude triangle hood on
hood off
so you could choose to put the hood on
or put the hood off now if you wear one
of the capes
so like if we went back to that Cape
right here the capes do not have hoods
at least the cave that I have does not
have a hood
so on The Capes you cannot do it oh my
goodness does this one actually
this is called a dragon hide protectors
cloak oh yeah I was like if that one has
a hood I totally missed it it does not
have a hood does not have a hood
so
I'm going to go back in here and let's
put the dark arts one back on
hood on always I know right it looks so
good
yeah I did link my Wizarding World
account
uh fledge this is uh this is on PS5 yeah
so I'm on PS5 oh and that was the other
thing I wanted to show you guys is which
uh mode we were on so I'm on PS5
performance mode right here
and if you are on a high refresh rate
display like a vrr you can do balanced
or HFR performance
but if you're not then you you pick one
of these three so I have found
when I've been playing this game for my
review or for my first impressions I
keep calling it a review I haven't even
beaten the game it's not a review it's
my early impressions
I've been playing mostly on performance
but I've been playing on my TV which
does have vrr here I'm running through a
capture card and even though my monitor
supports VR all right I can't enable it
um but I was tempted there's this
balance mode that's kind of like a 40
FPS mode but looks a little bit better I
just uh Fidelity it looks good but it's
just not like I prefer the frame rate I
want the fast frame rate
give me the frame rate now I'm not going
to show you guys this one right here I
want I feel like this one needs to be a
surprise
I feel like this one needs to be a
surprise
I know I love the hoods I love that you
can put them on with basically anything
Android won't let you donate what
what is happening
dude the
I'm not even gonna say that the
streaming Gods the streaming demons are
out tonight
they're out tonight
Jake says retro my Super Chat
oh no
okay wait no I do see I do see uh Jake
Super Chat I do see Jake's
so Andrew I don't know if maybe a mod
if Nico or elwin or any of the other
mods are here might be able to help
troubleshoot that I don't know what
would be going on there we our whole
stream died a little bit earlier guys
but Jake I do see Jake's Super Chat here
Jake thank you so much my trip to New
Zealand was nice
a lot a lot of people have been
traveling to New Zealand today had to
pay uh for an extra extra seat for my
console
nice nice
yeah I hear New Zealand is uh really
nice this time of year I hear it's very
nice
thank you for the Super Chat Jake very
much appreciated
very much appreciated
oh it's a limit Owen said no way
they shut down Andrew they shut him down
it won't let him donate anymore
yeah so talent's not gonna show you that
one I think that one your best
experiencing that for yourself
but here's the thing I told my I told
the moderators in Discord oh yeah so you
cannot jump on your broom immediately in
hogsmead
we're gonna have to get out a little bit
I did see someone else also asking about
the broom that was a bit of a surprise
to me I'm not gonna give away an exact
number but I'll just say you do not
immediately start with the broom
and it takes longer than you might think
okay we're still not out outside the
Hogwarts or the hogsmeade area just
enough yet
and how about now there we go
all right now we can hop on the Broom
all right so that was your that was your
first big tip was how the uh the
transmog and everything works wanna come
back on Wednesday Elwood says
oh I think there is
now I don't know
let me see if this command works
donate oh it doesn't exist
so there is we do have a stream elements
donation if people just literally wanted
to donate instead of uh going through
super chats
oh there went one volte with a super
chat what is up volte you know what I
think I can just put this on like oh
there we go like a little autopilot here
little autopilot let you guys just see
the world for a little bit
I'm gonna check my uh
My Stream elements here because
no one ever uses this it's just not
really a thing like I don't know people
just don't don't really do it on
YouTube that much but a lot of times on
uh twitch you'll see people just like
outright donate and that's like not
through a super chat a few bits or
anything so I mean if you will if if
people really wanted to
people really wanted to
here is
the stream elements
donate link
all right let me see if that works
now I don't know hopefully it would pop
up on stream I think I have it set up
pop up on stream
sorry guys we have somebody who
Andrew in the house tonight posting some
insane insane donations guys thank you
all so much for being here by the way
man it has been a rough uh
a rough start to the Stream
chat's been great you guys have been
awesome the game's been awesome
it's just the uh the Demons of of OBS
and YouTube streaming tonight I have not
been kind to me
yes CAD games we talked about that at
the beginning yeah yeah it is available
people on Steam you can now start that
preload
Draco with the one or the four months
for Drago thank you for the gift of
membership L one four months is four
months been a wicked ride
hey thank you so much Draco and Owen
thank you for the gifted membership
yeah also looks like oh there it is that
was like it looks like elwin's thing is
not popping up now
uh somebody was asking about
oh no it won't let Landon donate either
what is happening
oh my goodness it's pulling me in
it's pulling me in I have not explored
this area much guys but this like bog
area
it immediately forces you down like this
did I see Ben in the house as well
Ben what's up dude
welcome Ben
there are multiple save slots so like
when you're inside of a game
if I do save game right here yeah you
can see there's like all these multiple
so we got let's see one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten yeah it looks like ten here
now everybody's like can I I'm testing
the donation can I donate
guys thank you so much CAD games
Hogwarts Legacy with the 20 says CAD
games
I can't speak Hogwarts Legacy is
available to preload on PC for the Early
Access yes all right we'll just do this
this is not really like a main spoiler
or anything these little balloons you
guys have already seen these uh it's
like a little uh kind of like a little
mini Quest if you see these balloons oh
my goodness that was bad
just just kind of pop them as you go by
why am I why am I like having so much
trouble steering this all of a sudden
here we go
so let's pop that one right there there
we go
pop balloons one out of ten
so that's like a little challenge we've
already done a couple of those and then
it like resets so now I have to get 10
and then we had Draco and John so John
with the looks like a super chat no
question I didn't see a question there
John but thank you very much and then
Draco with the Super Chat this work it
did indeed Draco
it did indeed
dedicated Crouch button no I keep
looking for it no it's only when you use
disillusionment
only when you use disillusionment
this is this is on PS5 guys yeah PS5
performance mode it's what we're playing
on right now
and we're not really doing any story
spoilers we're just kind of exploring
the open world
showing showing off the map that is
right Ellen that is one thing I wanted
to do I wanted to test that so here's
what we're gonna do we are going to see
I'm going to go into the map right now
which if you don't want to see map stuff
hide your eyes but I'm not going to
really hover on anything for too long
so I'm going to mark this spot wait oh
wait wait wait
I don't think we're gonna be able to do
it Elwyn
I don't think we're gonna be able to do
it because
oh wait we can actually test it right
here
let me Mark I want to mark one of these
because I don't think we can fly over
this barrier right here
and I think that later in the game
to basically to open up
this whole section right here
I think you have to do something either
related to a quest or a story right in
here
although maybe I can just go let's try
this so all the flu Flames that you see
in uh the light gray here
that means I have not unlocked them the
green ones I have
another fast travel tip guys you do not
have to be at a flu flame fast travel
you can fast travel anywhere even in the
in the air so like right now see I'm
hovering on this one now you have to
have already been to it you have to have
visited that blue flame but I could just
hover on it hit Square
and then it's just gonna take me right
to that
we got some a few more donations here
trickling in a few more Super chats oh
my goodness who is this oh look so they
kind of get a little uh a little glitch
right there with the with the cloak
would you mind helping a wizard in
distress
not going to help you right now sir
sorry
not gonna help you at this moment
oh a cotton grass dug bog so right now I
have the oh my goodness I've never seen
this before
I've never seen this before you guys
[Music]
I've got presents all right we're not
gonna go over there though I'm gonna
fight this guy for you though
yeah these guys are too big they're big
boys
foreign
I need to find their weakness
oh that might be it right there
so when you whenever you do protego
if you hold triangle it will
automatically cast Stupify
automatically how's game audio by the
way not too loud no one said anything
about it yet so I'm assuming it's good
all right let's do an ancient Magic
thanks grass for blocking the ancient
magic right there
all right so you see I held it down
right there oh goodness there's another
one
the grass stop blocking the cool effect
incendio
just testing out stuff you know
yeah incendio seems to work the best
accio like no effect on these guys
whatsoever
levioso not really the pulso hit that
one incendio
maybe when they're backed up in the
water
oh he's almost down but I want to test
something
let's let's test something and then
we'll get to these super chats right
here maybe I have to wait until he is
nope didn't work
oh
do you guys see that so if you waited
till right when
that's the levitate the Doug bog by his
tongue remember the uh we saw that as a
little dueling feat in one of the uh
showcases I think it was Fifi yo your
vids got me hyped for this game be
playing on PC tomorrow nice
almost time almost time guys
uh is there a dedic oh I already
answered that dedicated Crouch button
and then let's see we had the we we are
all criminals does the PS5 have have to
feedback yes it does
it does indeed and it's really it really
comes into play with the what's going on
with these dragonflies I think they're I
think they're stuck right there it
really comes into play with the broom
especially
so like right now
the triggers especially the triggers are
really good
that resistance that you get
but yeah there's there's some haptic
feedback as well and some certain
certain moments of the game and then
Patrick with the Super Chat are they
going to let you be an evil wizard
so I'm gonna go get all good on my first
playthrough I will say 20 hours in I
have not gotten to any major
like story thing yet
so I don't know how much control we're
really gonna have over that
and if we're gonna really be able to
I mean Alan said Alan said got a little
Merlin puzzle right there I'll let you
guys do that for yourselves don't want
to spoil any any of the solutions on the
Merlin puzzle but what I wanted to test
Ellen's right what I wanted to test
earlier is I wanted to see how long it
takes to fly across the map
Daniel yeah what is that Dodge a trait
or a skill you'll you'll find out Daniel
you will find out
uh Jim on toast can you change the look
of your wand we were looking at this
earlier you can change the wand handle
again without I don't have a lot
unlocked so it's not going to spoil too
much for you guys but yeah you can
change the wand handle right here
so you're going to unlock these
throughout the game when you first get
your wand this part right here
is really set by you
and how you get your wand I'll let you
do that experience on your own if you
linked it to Wizarding World or not but
then you're going to start unlocking
these little handles right here
so pretty cool I I think they handled it
very well considering
considering the lore of how the wands
actually work in the World of Harry
Potter
but yeah what I wanted to do is I wanted
to see how far how long it would take us
to get across the map
foreign
yes if you guys didn't hear the streamla
steam preloading is up and available
it is up and available I don't even
Landon I don't have access to the mounts
yet
I've not found
I've not gotten the vivariums unlocked
yet I've not been able to write a
thestral hippogriff grabhorn none of
that yet
none of that
then we had Patrick with another Super
Chat Patrick already pre-loaded on Steam
can't wait for tomorrow
nice up
thank you for the Super Chat Patrick I
know dude so close so close so guys if
you're just tuning in wondering how's he
playing the game early uh I was
fortunate enough to see receive an early
review copy from WB so thanks so much to
them for sending me this copy for review
so that is why we were able to stream we
had a review up early today again I keep
saying review it's not a review it's
just my first impressions of the game I
may end up posting a full review later
after I've beaten everything now these
the blue ones I haven't seen the blue
ones before what happens if we
it's kind of like a time trial or
something
oh those make you go faster I miss them
though
[Music]
that's it oh it is okay same balloons
got it
but yeah I wanted to test and see how
far
the whole map is
but
there's an area that we can't
we can't get in here yet
well you know what we could try we could
try if there's anything big like
I don't wanna uh JP level 22 and no
major story so I'm just not I'm just not
going to show any story stuff for
tonight JP for tonight because we
originally promised this this was like a
supposed to be our countdown stream as
we counted down to playing with
everybody at midnight
this is not like a fake reaction I have
not I've not been to this area before I
haven't seen this
and then we had another one over here
wait where'd it go it was there was one
oh no there was another one wait is it
is it caged up over there
let's see if I can like oh no wrong
button wrong button
no no no no no can I bow don't leave
don't leave I want to bow
I don't know how to bow
I don't know how to Bow yet I don't know
if there's a command for that or
something
wait wait can I maybe I have to lock on
oh dude he's not happy
he or she is not happy
maybe I think I have to unlock that you
guys
I think I have to unlock that and I
haven't done it yet
I have not done it yet
for the Menagerie that could be it I
don't have that I don't even have that
open yet oh it's afraid I don't want to
bother him if he's afraid
horsey
oh man Ben was here earlier I don't know
if Ben's still hanging out
oh dude we got some poachers down here
oh no that's a that's a goblin camp
so I said this in my first impressions
I've not been bored at all
and the variety of stuff to do has been
it's been a pleasant surprise
because
with these open World Games man I mean
yeah you're gonna find some of the stuff
that's familiar but then there's some
things that again I don't want to spoil
too much
but you guys are gonna be like oh I I
didn't really expect that we'd be doing
something like that in this game it's
really cool somebody was asking about uh
can you jump off the broom mid-air you
cannot
you cannot so if I'm way up here the way
that you get off the broom is its circle
on PS5
and so if I push Circle right now they
just immediately start descending
oh Landing is unavailable trying to land
in a tree there and so then it just
takes you all the way down to since now
one thing you can do that is pretty cool
oh dude we're getting into all these
enemies that we're seeing up here are
matching Us in level let's get to a body
of water right here and I'll show you
something cool you can do
all right so we just need to head so I
have minimap turned off guys I just
think it's more immersive
normally the mini map is going to show
up in your bottom left of your screen
and I'm hoping I'm hoping that they
added like a dynamic HUD option to where
I can even hide that stuff over on the
right
the Spells and things all right so watch
this
let's see oh this might not be deep
enough
oh we need to get in some water where we
can actually
we need to swim in the water
come on jump over that
we gotta find something that's a little
bit deeper
losing your mind Jamie I know the first
impressions like that's why I don't want
to show you guys stuff from the
beginning
especially story stuff because some of
it is just so
so good especially the opening scene
like the very first thing you do
somebody wants to see the forest I will
show you the forest because that's where
the dark Hearts battle arena is
so I want to go through the forest later
and we can do some dark arts battle
arena stuff because they've already
showed that it's not going to be any big
oh dude there's that little shop again
all right so here's what I want to find
I want to get to some water
this is what happens man this is what
happens
it's so easy to get sidetracked do you
have to be members of Super Chat you
shouldn't Benjamin you shouldn't but
stream like I don't even know if you
guys could do anything it's it's amazing
anybody's even able to chat right now
because tonight everything about the
stream has hated us
everything about it has hated us
I'm making sure that no one uh
I don't know if Andrew said anything
about Andrew was gonna donate again
but
it put a limit on him I think Andrew
dropped a 400 donation earlier
and said that they were going to donate
500 if we showed off the wand
customization which we did but then it's
not letting them donate
so you should not have to be a member to
donate but honestly the way the stream's
been acting tonight nothing would
surprise me nothing would surprise me
Oh I thought it was Ben snow elwin I
thought it was Ben snow Jon Snow with
the Super Chat two hours to go and I
could play Let's Go congrats dude oh
Andrew Andrew is still here it's
blocking me it's so dumb wow
oh I'm sorry Andrew
but the streaming the streaming demons
as I'm calling them have they've had it
out to get us tonight all right
getting lots of good questions lots of
good questions lots of things people
want to see apparently Ben was a Dev on
the game The Tint that retro found is a
mini game I was in charge of he should
check it out
okay if it's just a mini game if it's
just a mini game I don't think the chat
would mind seeing that
I don't think they would mind seeing
that all right so here's what we're
gonna do we're gonna go I'm gonna unlock
this flu flame that I've had marked for
forever
and then
we're gonna come back and do this mini
game right here actually you know what
let's do the mini game right now we're
already here Ben I don't know I hope
you're still here Ben I hope you're
still here we're gonna do this mini game
and we're also going to take a look at
this sign and see what it says here
so we got King bridge that way
the danger bog dude something is
something is up with that bog for sure
it affects your your broom and
everything when you're flying
and then what does that say over there
and then we have Irondale that way
danger bog do not enter yeah we found
that out extreme Danger
extreme Danger
it's not streamy demons it's peeves
I don't know what it is dude but uh
the streaming demons have given us one
issue after another tonight with the
stream oh here we go guys and we had a
chat a member of the chat earlier Ben I
don't know if Ben is still here Ben
worked on a Dev at Avalanche worked on
this little mini game that we're about
to do right here Priya Treadwell
see what this is all about hello
do you have anything for sale hello
or is this the wrong place this might be
the wrong one I'm Priya Treadwell at
your service and I sell a variety of
traveling necessities
oh okay uh or I did I thought I met
another are you related to Nora
Treadwell why yes she's my wife
brilliant historian PS5 she's pursuing
Merlin's life's work oh yes her and she
introduced me to our work did meet her
involved in it now as well this is early
early game not not main story don't
worry don't worry let's be rather
brilliant as well at any rate I hope
that you'll think of me whenever you
find yourself in need of traveling
supplies it's been a pleasure meeting
you
pleasure meeting you I don't I don't
think this is the mini game I think
we're in the wrong spot may I see your
where's the sale
and why are you set up with your shop
just like in the middle of this
dangerous bog that's what I want to know
family antique broom 2500.
somebody said uh yeah it's PS5 PS5 is
what we are playing on
and then we had let's see another Super
Chat
from Brook D been following since the
Fortnight days proud of you thank you so
much Brooke I'm pretty sure that's my
sister guys pretty sure that's my sister
thank you very much
Benjamin thought it was the mini game
tint they are found in hamlets during
the day oh it did just change over we're
gonna we will find it Ben we will find
it
wrong wrong tent
a lot of Window Shopper right what why
are you exactly stationed out here
all right so we don't really need any of
this let's see
you could always use wig in my potions
but I'm gonna I'm not gonna spend
anything right now
so nice and somebody was asking if I had
seen day all right another Pro tip the
game tells you a lot of this stuff but
there's so much to this game guys
there's so much to this game I'm gonna
make a video for a lot of these but you
can skip ahead in time and you don't
have to be in a specific area you could
be anywhere I pull up the map right here
and look at that R3 R3 down there says
wait
R3 says wait so I'm going to press R3 to
wait wait here to advance time from day
to night or night today I'm gonna hit it
there we go
and the loading is pretty quick
pretty quick and it looks like are we at
early morning now
hold on
whoops didn't mean to do that
oh wait I think maybe it was hold on
maybe the bog is throwing everything off
thank you for the Super Chat that was
see we had Brooke and then we had
Patrick was looking at other streams on
Hogwarts so I can see yours is the best
by far I had to become a member Patrick
thank you so much dude
that's right I missed did I miss Patrick
becoming a member I did Patrick I'm so
sorry
welcome to house rack and tour my friend
enjoy the emotes
and enjoy uh if you're a Discord person
we have a special role in the Discord as
well
and discounts on our merch if you're
interested in any of that guys thank you
so much for all the love tonight it has
been a
bit a little bit of a cluster a little
bit of cluster to start the Stream
but you know what we're here now we're
enjoying Hogwarts Legacy and we're
having a good time everybody's here you
found the right stream we're in the
right place oh that's interesting
okay yeah it is it is morning it's just
it's just like early early morning so
it's taking a bit for the sun to rise so
Benjamin there guys indirectly
confirming
that night and day you're gonna have
different missions different things you
can do
based on the time of day so I'm just
gonna peek in here
dude hold on
that looks an all this is not something
I've experienced yet it looks an awful
lot like the glacier symbol
no no it was worth a try worth a try
whoa whoa whoa I heard something
I heard something
it was though I thought I thought that
was actually it I thought it was about
to open all right let's try uh
nope now look there
no look there thank you so much Patrick
uh reefs in a Super Chat let's see
oh no I don't think it came through
I don't think he came through no there
it is there it is oh my gosh I'm so
sorry Reef so sorry that we missed that
thank you for the Super Chat how far are
you in the main story still have a lot
to play so I have played uh I think the
in-game counter it must like I don't
know not count if you're in menus or
something because I've spent a lot of
times in menus
so it said when I started playing
tonight that I was at like 15 16 hours
but I've played more than 20 because I
have the the footage for it
but it's hard to say like how far I am
in the story what I could show you is
like if you go into the challenges here
there's my percent complete on a lot of
this stuff look at that room of
requirement zero so I guess I'm 33
through
33 through
and that's been about 20 hours and I've
like I said I've been doing I've spent a
lot of time in menus like customizing
stuff
21 on combat 16 still got a lot of
expiration to do Field Guide Pages
making some pretty good Headway on those
but thank you very much for the Super
Chat Reeve thank you very much and I'm
really enjoying the story too really
enjoying it
but I'm glad I caught your uh comment
there glad I caught your comment and
sorry I missed the Super Chat yeah we
got the we got the game early thanks to
WB guys they sent us a copy for review
so you can check out the
First Impressions on the channel and
we're just hanging out right now playing
uh just kind of going through the open
world not really showing anything Story
related
so if you hold down L2 you get kind of
like this little
targeting so you can zoom in there
or you can just kind of run around
freely and then if I hit I don't think I
can lock onto anything right here
but R3 locks on to targets when you have
some in the area
can you have a pet owl
so there is an owl I guess I could show
you guys the uh
somebody was saying this is a Merlin
puzzle
if it is it's a different one than what
I've seen so far
that's all I'll say so darn it Elwyn I
don't think we're gonna be able to do
what we want it to do I wanted to try
and see I wanted to see how long I guess
we could still try it with oh man that's
a pretty good section of the map there
pretty good section of the map though
that we wouldn't have access to
I think this must be something Story
related a treasure vault
see the Merlin puzzles are marked by
these right here I'm not going to do any
of those because I think it's so tonight
guys the stream is just a little bit
different because normally this was
supposed to be a countdown stream but
fortunately we got the game early so I
was like you know what there's no point
in me just not playing at all so we're
just gonna play and show off kind of
non-spoilery stuff but starting tomorrow
uh we're gonna be on Twitch in the
morning around 10 a.m eastern time then
we're just like we're going all out like
I'm gonna be doing story stuff I'm gonna
be doing all the side quests and stuff
like that but tonight because of the
community that's been such a huge part
of me doing this channel up until this
point
um yeah I just I had to make sure that I
didn't spoil too much for them on the
first on the first night
guys welcome to the new subscribers
thank you all thank you all
I'm Gryffindor yeah Gryffindor
we can estimate by yeah we could we
could like do some estimates what I
really want to figure out guys I want to
figure out how long it takes you to
actually completely fly across the map
now see like you think people
the thing about Maps man scale
scale matters right like the scale is
everything because if I just like if I
just go like this you're like oh that's
a pretty pretty small map but then let
me show you this
that is Hogwarts right there
Hogwarts is huge like all the stuff that
you can do inside there is enormous it's
CR it's just it's crazy and so you see
kind of the space that it takes up on
the map I assume it's the biggest like
in uh inside area in the game I assume
that I don't know I'm again I've not
beaten it yet like you can see as I'm
scrolling through look at all these
things that I haven't discovered yet
so many different things that we haven't
discovered
but yeah I really just wanted to start
up here
and just fly all the way and see how
long it would take but we are blocked
off right here so my guess
I still think it's something Story
related although this says treasure
Vault right here
this says treasure vault
now it could be something I've noticed
with dude I keep
revelio
dude revalios like your go-to
revelio is a huge help
I'm gonna use that a lot probably gonna
be your most used spell
your most used spell
oh wait we do have something showing up
over here it looks like a creature
oh yeah these little things oh
the leaping Toadstool caps now what we
could try
is I want to get up above it
and see if there's anything that will
help us unlock this because if we can
get in there
and if it's not something Story related
well then I would be happy to show it
James it's Sue say hi hello James and
Sue welcome
you all still streaming as well or did
you uh did you finish up
man I tell you James it's been a it was
a rocky start to the Stream came for me
tonight
we have all sorts of technical issues
not with the game but with with stream
related things oh so these things right
here are called Landing zones
and if you just land on one right here
there you go landing plan or Landing
platforms excuse me
and so far that's like uh that's the one
thing I've discovered I don't know if
they really do anything else or if
they're just something that shows up on
your map
we can go get in some more combat here
in a second
but hold on what I'm really trying to do
is I want to see
I want to see if we can get inside here
anyway
that's what I'm trying to do
oh Benjamin oh
guys we got a Dev in the house Benjamin
dropping some tips tip for the vault use
revelio in the areas around it okay we
were we were close we were casting
revelio
so what I what I figured out Benjamin is
some of the
Merlin puzzles it's like I didn't have
the right spell yet or maybe there was a
way and I just didn't figure it out but
there was this one Merlin puzzle I'm
pretty sure I'm gonna have to come back
with bombarda I don't have bombarda yet
all right all right this is good though
this is good
uh Dragonfire I'm off work I'm off work
until Friday so
we are I'm locked in dude I'm locked in
I'm ready to play
I don't know how long we'll go tonight
but we're gonna be uh if you're in
Twitter on Twitter or in our Discord
I've posted my schedule for the week
there
all right so I bet we can go and at
least get this
Blue Flame
oh wait wait wait hold on see see dude
this is what happens constantly you
start you you're on you're on a path to
do something and then you see something
else see now I'm just like wait what's
this this train track right here now I
have to I have to follow this we have
like we have to see
where this leads
okay so this goes up here
oh okay I think this is moonstone over
here
now what's interesting I've been
watching people I've been watching a
couple streams people playing this today
and everybody's been doing accio on this
which makes sense right
do accio and you get it what I don't
think you have to do accio because what
I've been doing is I just run up hit R2
and then see they kind of automatically
comes
I think that's one right there yep there
we go so they just automatically come so
it doesn't have to be accio on that
and you use the Moonstone inside the
room of requirement so that's what's
gonna let you
okay I'm hearing
you gotta listen to all sorts of little
cues revelia and sound effects in this
game
oh dude I hear I hear something
something's listening
oh oh oh okay
my son and I were trying to figure out
how to get this can I hop off right here
oh
wait
you could just search right from the
broom
no way
oh my gosh we were we were right here
the other night
and I was thinking dude we're gonna have
to do something man we were getting
really deep with it my eight-year-old
was thinking we're gonna have to get
something on the train tracks we're
gonna have to push it all the way up and
then it's gonna rise all the way to the
top and I told him I said I think you
might be right that's genius but no you
just could fly your broom over there I
thought we had to actually Hop Off
too funny
too funny
yeah good good point James thanks for
making this game Benjamin for real dude
thanks for all your hard work
thanks for all the work I can't imagine
guys what it's like for for developers
who have spent so much time
I mean think about that I don't there's
all sorts of different jobs right but
most of the things
I feel like most professions out there
you get to see how inconvenient
the rewards you get to see your work
a lot sooner than something like I guess
it's like really anything with the Arts
you know filmmaking
video games writing a book I mean you
have to go so long just toiling away on
your own
well you got the team of course when it
comes to video games before anyone sees
it and so now to have it going out into
the world it's got to be an amazing
moment an amazing moment multiple years
of your life dedicated something
now see Benjamin Benjamin we want to try
out Benjamin's mini game as well I need
to go back to the bog
collecting all this Moonstone so we can
just fully deck out the room of
requirement
I know Ellen that's a good point yeah so
on Twitch you can actually you can give
memberships on twitch or YouTube but on
Twitch you can so there's the targeting
right there if you do R3
but I have to say even without targeting
it's pretty it's pretty reliable just
like if you kind of aim in the general
area
all right this looks like an enemy camp
over here
but we're gonna try
to First do what Benjamin said about
casting revelio gave us a hint here
around
see there we go we hear something over
here it's like okay now I'm distracted I
need to go over there I need to check
that out
Patrick with the 10 gifteds
Patrick thank you so much for the 10
gifted memberships
guys if you just received one of those
gifted memberships make sure you thank
Patrick you now have access to all the
Emoji in the chat
Patrick I think Patrick is uh I don't
know if Patrick's been in the Stream
before
Patrick I'm glad you found this and
appreciate you spreading the love
sharing the love with others in the chat
tonight
but yeah if you guys didn't see there
you can cast revelio even even on Broom
even when you're flying on the Broom so
Benjamin gave us a little hint
oh okay wait we got we got something
right here
I think this is just a uh
okay that that looks
that looks significant
and we got a little sound effect on it
too
revelio
okay that one's just lacewing flies
[Music]
no spells Luna other than other than
revelio from what I've seen
yeah yeah it's for the uh I think it was
glacias yeah that's what it looked like
to me
[Music]
so maybe yeah maybe if we uh
let's go to Glaciers nope
see now I don't even remember where we
were
PS5 guys PS5 that's what we're playing
on PS5 performance mode right now
revelio
here it is it's over here okay so there
it is there it is and to get into this
area this says treasure vault
can't interwall mounted it looks like a
picture
of the spell glacias which we have we've
tried casting it here
wait
did you see that
revelio
excuse me
okay okay wait wait wait maybe it's a
maybe you have to keep spamming it
[Music]
let me through
okay clearly definitely something to do
with glacias our hint from Benjamin
accio you think accio
freeze button freeze door that's what we
tried originally
or actually no we did the we did the
door first
but Benjamin's hint was was to cast
revelio like around the area here
around the area
try putting a rock on it
can you get a more powerful cold spell
uh maybe
maybe oh I can't hop on my broom right
there
there we go now I can
try to back up right next to the door
you do it oh my gosh
no way no way no way no way
let me in there let me in there
[Music]
no
[Music]
yo welcome to the new members
okay wait who just got a uh
wait we had Tim wait wait we had 20
gifted dude Patrick it threw me off
it threw me off because I saw the tin
again we've had so many stream errors
tonight I was thinking it was a uh
I was sick it was another error
dude thank you so much for the 20 gifted
memberships guys if you got one of those
new memberships you can uh use the emoji
that we have in the chat now
you also get a special Discord role
exclamation point Discord if you're not
a member of the Discord yet you can join
it
oh revelio
purple purple spell
it's a weighted lock find the item with
with said color spell
so fun dude this is so fun ice and fire
I don't have a Resto momentum yet
do not have a rest of momentum
it's not glacious it's incendio oh oh
wait you think like the opposite
maybe it's showing you the ice symbol
and you need and you need to do the fire
incendio
I liked it it was a good idea
I liked where your head was at
dude like it
it starts to open
it starts to open when you cast glacias
man
oh come on I was in
I was in that time
isn't cyndia But first you got to put a
rock over it it sounds like arno's Arno
might be another Dev or Arno has already
done this
we got it do we have a rock over here
no we do not have any rocks
I don't even have a
wingardium yet so
I don't know if I could get what I
needed over there all right we know what
it's daytime
it's daytime so there is oh wait
a little statue right here
hello you oh well well looky what we
have here and look at what that symbol
ladies and gentlemen
look at that symbol that we have there
oh my gosh stuff also with the launch
the pulso with an enormous launch
oh but hey not a bad not a bad spot
welcome guys welcome to all the
newcomers thank you all for stopping by
and hanging out we are not showing any
Story related items tonight so if you
don't want to see anything story don't
worry we're just kind of showing off the
open world showing some of the side
quests showing some of the exploration
uh and if you're wondering how we got
the copy early that uh was courtesy of
WB they sent us a copy for review so
thank them so much for that and we also
have a video up on the Channel with kind
of our first impressions of the game
okay wait so it's here
okay
let's go
let's go oh my goodness
wow who said it it was not incendio
it was not incendio but
who was that Arno Arno you did put me on
the right path though by saying The Rock
by saying the rock you put me on the
right path or no you know what I bet I
bet there's another one I bet there's
another one somewhere else in the world
that isn't sindio right it makes sense
it makes sense that they would have more
than one
oh man okay all right guys
we're probably gonna be seeing some
different enemies now this is not story
don't worry this is just a side thing
but again I know people are very uh
particular about spoilers so
non-story stuff but we could be seeing
some enemies in here
I see some people thinking maybe spiders
lumos
I don't know
it's usually you're able to spot the
spiders long before they actually
get too close to scary
you can spot them long before that long
long before it Patrick with another 10
gifted memberships Patrick what is
happening my man what is happening thank
you so much Patrick I
spring
spur because we're in this like creepy
area you know what let's just go ahead
and go all stealth right now here's what
we're gonna do we're gonna do revalio
we're gonna do the disillusionment
[Music]
Patrick thank you so much dude
the man guys if you got one of the
gifted memberships
make sure you think Patrick enjoy the
emotes in the chat
and then we had a 1.99 super chat from
am uh can we see your first ever
reaction to the story
so I did not record my first ever
reaction I um
I just the first time I was like I need
I want to focus on this for review
uh for My First Impressions but you can
hear my my first impressions I posted
that video today but as far as like live
nah I haven't recorded that I mean I
will be playing through the story again
probably multiple times I should
investigate oh my goodness
yes you should
okay we got some creepy looking cough in
here
[Music]
foreign
looks like you'll have to wait oh no
Jake what's wrong
yeah dude uh little fear you have to
learn all the Spells
you have to learn all the Spells
all right so we got a couple things we
can try here
all right
now we have kind of like cheerful music
all right so I'm thinking
let's try confringo
all right good good good
no no not good
revelio
is that a skull
it is a skull
okay can we do the same on you
no can we do
no
all right so we have the blue one right
here we were definitely right casting
that up there and then we also have that
yellow or gold
now another thing we might be able to do
is cast incendio on these torches
no
can't light them couldn't find them
come on stay lit
t-love it's so good
I'm having a blast
having a blast
can you get the Early Access uh so I my
I'm playing an early copy from WB they
sent over for review but if you bought
the deluxe version
the digital deluxe version it is slowly
coming online depending on where you
live in the world
so some people can already play it it is
about 10 o'clock Eastern Time right now
so for us in the U.S anybody who's
gotten the digital version you got about
two hours to go two hours to go
yeah somebody was saying repair I mean
we could be like what's the point of
this looks intriguing it I I agree retro
I mean it does look intriguing
but it's like the it's the bunnies of a
skeleton
all right let's try it okay can fringo
on that doesn't do anything it was
glazius that got us in here
can we hop on the broom in here oh dude
imagine imagine if we could have hopped
on the Broom
all right we will try we we do have
repairow we could try it
see where did I put repair oh I might
have to okay it's right there repair
I feel like we need to get these down
apparo doesn't seem to be
anything
1pm Eastern Time
uh Joe it depends on what system you're
on if you're on PC
I think that's correct if your console
us then it's uh it's like
it's midnight Eastern Time
repair
how do you get the line that tracks your
quest so you don't have to use the mini
map good question we talked about this
in our video so if you mark something I
think it has to be actually it might
work right now
you see this uh
so the golden one I think is related to
story yeah that's where I'm supposed to
go next for the story but I'm not
showing that stuff tonight
so I think if I push up on the d-pad
yeah there you go so you push up on the
d-pad and you get this little Golden
Trail that you can just follow
but you have to have it marked first so
you can mark it by either going into the
map right here or you go over to the
quest page I don't want to pull it up I
don't want to spoil people on the quests
tonight but you can go there and you can
mark it from there too and then once you
get that Gold Line
the gold dots right there then you just
hit up on the d-pad
oh for it is redorian helping out with a
lot of the uh same questions
appreciate it appreciate it
I don't have wingardium yet Elijah it is
possible I have encountered areas where
where I couldn't do anything yet
and see I can't I also can't lock on to
the bones here
oh
okay wait that's interesting
but usually it's like when you do
revelio it's like the blue things that
are important
imagine if it was like uh
is it um
is it dark souls three
there's a couple of them where you like
have to lay in the coffin right to
trigger the uh
trigger the next a little secret
see if we can repair all this
[Music]
prove dangerous if I'm not
okay oh wait wait was that a hint like
is this something that I'm supposed to
use right here
can you pull one to the other yeah see I
tried like
hold on
hold on Rebellion
okay so the skeletons themselves right
here are not highlighted
wait what is that up there that's blue
I don't think we have access to that
area yet
or no that was outside
wait you guys don't think
what if I have to bring this
wait a second
imagine if the door just instantly
closed on me
I wonder if we can use this to jump on
it
get in there
get in there
oh yeah no problem Patrick no problem I
mean like I said this this first night
when we first when we planned it tonight
was gonna be like a countdown stream so
we were gonna do a lot of stuff counting
down
going back and looking at a lot of old
videos which I would still like to do at
some point but once everybody started
streaming the game it was kind of like
Ugh
I have it so
let's do it
dude if this I don't think it's gonna
give me enough
oh
not gonna give me enough height that
clearly like right there I just need to
try every spell on that
accio nothing
else
I mean that
yeah
imagine if it was Expelliarmus
like it's seen as his weapon or
something
giving just enough to make it even
better nice
I don't have wingardium yet Arno
I don't have it unlocked yet I do have
just the gate yes you should revelio
investigate retro
come on
why are you not doing a good job of
investigating
so the first thing we did there was a
pile of bones up
wait a second hold on maybe this is like
a different lock-on that we did
that we didn't have before
are you serious
okay well
revelio all right we got more skeletons
down here now
more skeletons
can we use them
skeletons
they've got to be related somehow right
like they've got to be
dead on the platform in Castro pero
oh
it was a good idea
that's what I was thinking then I was
thinking destroy these
I was thinking destroy those
I've been that earlier in here I don't
think that's the same bin Ben Stark
I don't we have a Dev who was in here
dropping a few hints
oh you think it's like it looks more
blue to me but yeah we tried to pull so
we tried Act
wait did that just move
d
I'm throwing everything I got at it guys
so confringo 100 percent
is what destroyed these
like this skeleton right here
revelio and now he's got this like see
this gold
box on the altar wait what is this
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
how do we get these stairs to appear
glacias and then glacias
you guys think it's the skeleton you
think it's tied to the skeleton
me destroying the skeleton
[ __ ] on the platform you think okay okay
we'll try that
let me do uh
yeah so you can't really
because I don't have wingardium yet so
you kind of just have to use
like sort of use accio for it now how do
I I need to like release
go away levioso
go away levioso
deactivate
okay there's definitely somebody they
keep saying repair on the skeletons
which skeletons
repair
I've reparalled everything why is like
where's the cheerful music coming from
I'm wondering if I have to get all of
these to fall down
repeater
replace the skin like this one's like
doing this kind of weird
oh it finally fell
okay
I think that means it's morning outside
is like our cheerful music
come on you could jump on that
all right so here's what we found out so
far guys if you're just tuning in
top some top tier content we got going
right here we are trying to figure out
how to get
this invisible
sort of platform that we can see it here
when we cast reveillo
to form
the way that we got into this place we
had to put this block on a little switch
outside then we casted a glacias on it
okay uh yeah
like there's enough people in chat that
keep saying
point at the skeletons on the floor and
repair the target
okay all right so I'm trying to lock on
you can't you can't lock on
I'm doing this it's not highlighting any
skeletons guys
not highlighting any of them
there's enough people saying it that I
feel like this is actually the solution
Target any of the skeletons
oh wait I have to be on the platform
I've got presents
Oni savior with the Super Chat
thank you so much
Jake buddy I'm not sure what you're
talking about do I think it will save
your game
Ben said don't aim
see chat you guys telling me to
highlight and aim come on dude
rapera
like enough people are saying repero
skeletons
wait and maybe see like that one that's
glowing right there it must relate
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
like this one needs this one needs a
head right here can I move him let's see
if we can move it
can't move them anymore
excuse me
excuse me Mr skeleton what the heck
we just had to like gather them into a
pile
okay now now repair is gonna work it's
gonna work
gosh it didn't work oh wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait
we're getting a highlight now though
we're getting a highlight
we're getting somewhere we're getting
somewhere
oh come on
there's more up top you guys
there's more up top
all the skeletons are needed
all of the skeletons
come on skeletons
gather around
see if we can just launch you guys
oh oh wait skeletons skeletons are you
are you ready now apparel
relatives
come on skeletons I need some stairs
makes a staircase
oh my gosh this is too funny
I feel like you guys are lying to me
chat
I feel I feel like chat's leading me you
guys are cute you guys are leading me
along aren't you
I don't like it I I don't I don't I
don't like
you guys are leading me along
oh
wait yes I think he oh my gosh
Pro Gamer ladies and gentlemen Pro Gamer
I better go before it disappears I don't
want it to leave I do not want to leave
w
that's it we're done I'm going pro
Hogwarts Legacy Pro
face sign me up
it's I mean that clip alone guys just
the contract where's the contract
all right I'm gonna I'm just gonna say
it though
I'm just gonna say it
I can't get beat
it's done it's over
I'm just gonna say there there was
something wonky I mean you guys could
see I was casting all the Spells I think
you're just supposed to get them all
like gathered into one area whoever kept
saying repair was not reperto did
nothing for me did nothing the whole
whole time it was just getting enough of
those bones to fall and collect down
there
and then what was it I did I think I did
I think I did one last like accio and
then as soon as it brought him over to
that one right there
that was it dude
that was it
Patrick you did call I see I thought
some of the people saying skeleton
staircase I thought you guys knew
thought ice oh that must be it they knew
somehow dude we're gonna get like watch
it's gonna be
all that work
it's gonna be like a lower level pair of
it's gonna be like a scarf it's gonna be
a lower level scarf than what I already
have that's that's my prediction let's
see
Whimsical sorcerer hat
that is a lower level than what I have
however most important thing let's see
what it looks like let's see what it
looks like
let's see
how it looks
all right oh wait it's not going to show
up right now we've got to turn off the
hood hood off
and then
now we can see what it looks like
oh wait that's not it because
I think it's that one the green one
right here yeah Whimsical sorcerer hat
so the cool thing about it is I can sell
this and I will still keep it as a um
what they call an appearance it's like
this one the reason it keeps showing up
like that
is because I've already changed the
appearance of it
same thing for this one like this one
right now that I have equipped
I've already changed the appearance to
basically be an invisible visible
faceware
and then if you just hit
Square that's going to reset it
see how that reset the uh the appearance
there and then I'll change it back to
that mask
this was by the way this uh what you
guys see me wearing right now I said at
the beginning of the stream this was my
kids my my eight-year-old and
four-year-old this is brought to you by
them right here all right let's see
which one is the most I still think this
blue one yeah 158 is the highest level
blocking what I get oh yeah oh it does
block it there's not a good spot for
there's really not a good spot in this
game for um
dress up like Doom
oh did I completely take off the hat
good call yeah I need the uh
oh I put it back on I put it back on but
yeah even if you so it doesn't show me
wearing the Hat because when I go into
the appearance I have it set to
Invisible headwear however I still keep
the stat boost for it still keep the
stat boost
well that was a trip ladies and
gentlemen
that was quite a trip but we're done
now unfortunately
we did all of this because we were
hoping we were hoping that it would cut
some sort of path
through here however it did not
and now looking at this a little bit
closer
oh I think we're just gonna have to like
walk up this mountain
so we're trying what we're trying to do
chat is we're trying not to show story
stuff
and we want to show I'd love to be able
to show off the full length of the map
and us actually time it just flying
across walk gross I know right
right
redirected yo
who redirected here Cindy who redirected
was it our buddy expecto go
do they do hosts on YouTube they do um
yeah it's they call it redirects on
YouTube is what they call it James and
Sue hey let's go
James and Sue thank you all so much
hope you all had a wonderful stream
tonight it's it's just been surreal
hasn't it like this game's finally being
out
oh no wait I think that is showing me
the path right there I think that is
showing me the path
James I hope you're able to get some
sleep dude I saw
sound like James pulled an all-nighter
last night you guys
from what he was saying in his stream
but yeah James James and Sue just two
awesome people I feel like most of you
watching right now probably already know
them but if you don't expect to go over
on
Twitter now as well no more underscore I
don't know if you told that story yet
James
I'll tell it here then you I'll let you
know you could tell it when you're on
your stream too whoa whoa whoa musical
cues you always have to pay attention
oh I think we're getting close to a
little encampment or something up there
enemy camp
okay so we can use the broom right here
oh but then see there's that golden that
Golden Aura telling you where you can't
go
so I was just uh I was trying to
I think I was just trying to pull up
James's Twitter account the other day
and I a lot of times I'll just type in
if I'm not already on Twitter so I was
like twitter.com
expect it'll go
oh you can't Dismount here no way
we gotta figure out how to uh
get over here but it's it's entirely
possible it's something Story related
that we just can't do yet
so yeah I was like twitter.com expecto
go this doesn't exist
you didn't tell a story yet oh man all
right
so it said it doesn't exist
and it was like what
James got James got banned on Twitter
Elon banned him what's happened James is
gone
but no James wasn't gone James used to
be I think it was expecto underscore go
so I dm'd him right away I was like dude
I was just trying to find
I was just trying to look you up and
apparently no one has the expecto go
just just expect to go nobody has that
on Twitter right now
and so he looked into it and now he is
officially
expecto go on Twitter and I think I'm
pretty sure that on Instagram as well I
know you're that on YouTube and
and twitch as well but if you haven't
already checked him out before guys uh
James is just an all-around all-around
good dude
all around good dude been covering
Hogwarts Legacy
for a long time now long time he and I
got to meet in person for the first time
at the LA event when they invited us out
early
dude what is that I keep
I keep rocks right there
well unfortunately guys I think we're
gonna have to abandon our quests right
now man I was really trying to just show
off the full map
we'll try hold on I'm not easily
deterred game
I'm not easily deterred
so were we trying to get
now when I highlight on the map
that right there that's where we just
were that treasure vault is where we
were we've already explored that
now we're trying to get I'm just trying
to get to that flu flame first
and then we're trying to get through
that area but it's it's very possible it
could be a story thing
oh no Benjamin's still here Benjamin's
still here hold on hold on Goblin
Gauntlet Cavern leads to the coast you
can get there
or die trying oh
Benjamin Benjamin Benjamin that's all
that's all you had to say dude that's
all you had like
all right I know I know despite what
chat just witnessed there
wasn't my best gaming moment
the the bones I'm blaming on the bones
they were acting a little bit weird
there but however
I'm not bad at games okay I'm not bad
my am I like the greatest player you're
ever gonna see no but I'm not bad
so you you give a challenge you put down
a challenge for me
I'm going for it dude
I'm going for it we're all in
so hearing
you can die trying oh oh we're trying
we're trying Benjamin
no no not not only we're gonna try we're
we're
Benjamin's like he has no idea they're
level 40.
I'm level 22. I actually have no idea no
idea what level they are up here
but yeah so here's what we're trying to
do we're trying to get through here
I'm gonna scroll back up I want to see
exactly what Benjamin said go till
midnight Jake we'll see dude we'll see
uh Peter I'm playing on the performance
but that's performance is not the 30 FPS
mode performance is the the 60 60 mode
so yeah then they also have fidelity
um which is the 30. and then they have a
Fidelity with Ray tracing which is going
live with the day one no no patch until
the 10th Connor I just saw that comment
interesting
so Draco I don't think the day one patch
is out yet since we've been playing it
for review there was one patch that I
saw
that I installed but I I do not think it
was the
day one patch quote unquote
okay hold on I'm looking for Benjamin's
comment it was something about Goblin
get your curses a snake boy how are you
going about three must-have I haven't
gotten that I haven't gotten them yet in
the game
we could show off the dark arts Arena
here shortly though so Goblin Gauntlet
Cavern leads to the coast all right
Goblin Gauntlet Cavern is what we are
looking for here guys but all of these
just say treasure vault
dug bog layer
very Lair I've not seen any in theories
yet
and Furious and fury
all right so that could very well be
oh
practice flying your spiers that's for
an assignment
for a class
do as minigame oh yeah the mini game too
the mini game
or Benjamin Benjamin's like darn it I'm
just waiting for him to try this
minigame
and now I'm just okay let's make sure
I think it just turned night so guys you
can change the time so you just go into
your map hit R3
one thing I'll suggest this for a patch
Benjamin
you guys have as if you guys don't have
enough to do already
but um it'd be awesome if there was
something on this screen that like said
change from night to day or whatever
because when it first like when you
first go today it's actually hard to
tell at first because it's so dark
like that the early morning hours so I
think
oh no that's that's definitely I think
that's definitely night so let's do it
again plus there's also weather changes
too
all right let's wait one more time
oh that's for sure for sure yeah Sun
just is rising yeah there we go there we
go all right so Benjamin Benjamin
Benjamin wanted us to do
a side quest a little mini game
that I believe was over near the bog
area
so yeah I think right in here I'm just
gonna Mark a random spot there
I refuse to get sidetracked we're going
back to the Goblins we're going back to
that layer 100 percent
but Benjamin here showing love showing
support in the Stream a Dev who worked
on the game show him some love guys this
has got to be a big moment for them
finally finally getting to release this
after I know it's been more than five
years that they've been working on this
game
and Benjamin worked on one of the mini
games here in this area one of the mini
games
Elden ring Hogwarts universe
uh it runs well it runs very well on so
I've been playing PS5 performance mode
now this one like
oh man see I thought this was it but
this is just Prius shop right here
all right so this is what we're looking
for though chat we're looking for like
one of these little pop-up areas
foreign
it right now I know dude we're getting
close we're getting close by the way PC
players you guys can preload two now you
guys can preload too Chandler and the
official Hogwarts Legacy accounts they
posted
good on them for that too good on them
for I don't know what all they have to
do to
you're the UFL yeah yeah yeah we know
that
is it trying to tell me like do I not
have the best gear on or something
uh Elwyn or Nico any mods that are here
if you guys see Benjamin post
where exactly to find the mini game
make sure to uh at me
at me in the chat
DC could reload on Steam but not Epic
uh glumpnar if you have a capable
display with a vrr
or that Sports 120 hertz there is a I
think it's called HFR performance what
they're calling it oh
I said I would get sidetracked I said I
wouldn't get sidetracked I said
I wouldn't get sidetracked but guys this
could be it this could oh no this is a
nasal
get in here
oh he's a traveling vendor
that's so awesome
oh my gosh that's so awesome
sometimes at hamlets during the daytime
dude that
see I didn't even know about that guys
I've been playing the game 20 plus hours
didn't even know that there were
traveling vendors
where the mini games move around that is
awesome Benjamin well I will I will keep
an eye out
I will keep an eye out and if we had
sidetracked right right right
I will keep an eye out there they're
apparently in the various in the various
hamlets
surrounding
so not in the Bog that was that was
previous shop that we we thought was it
so now I guess we just explore we're
gonna try to get into this
this is our goal this is our goal for
the for however long it takes we want to
get into here
this is where we want to get into so you
know what I'm going to go to this Bandit
camp
classified as a medium Bandit Camp here
and we're gonna see
if that's where we need to go
so Benjamin said it was something to do
with the a goblin Camp which very well
could be this right here however
apparently it's going to be pretty high
level
for where we're at right now oh dude oh
man
here
this is the largest area I've seen so
far
like in terms of the uh
enemies and stuff we got trolls I do not
know Avada Kedavra
all right all right this could be rough
this could be rough
see I can't I can't like rescue the
measles yet guys I haven't unlocked that
yet all right as soon as we're gonna try
22 we're at level 22. we got this
we got this but we are going to go in
stealth first
stealth first see what we can do we do
have some ancient magic attacks or we
have one we can try to build up another
oh no no no he's looking my way
does the tree protect me
or a video
feels like I've been at this for hours
all right
got him oh dude that troll did that
troll
controller's supposed to be dumb come on
should not have heard me
let's get it over to inspect though
he's inspecting
I'm not sure what the level cap is
I'm okay with not knowing I've heard 40
but I don't I don't know if that's if
that's 100 or not
Revenue
all right so I feel like oh dude there's
some up there too
I think what we should try to do
is maybe go out and fly in
and try to take out some of these
goblins that are up top first
what's funny is
we don't even know if this is the way to
get where we're trying to go
so let's go over here
of course we have to come out of our
disillusionment
all right we can cast revello though
from the broom
oh no he sees me he sees me get down all
right let's land right let's land oh
lady is unavailable don't do that to me
Avalanche okay there we go there we go
it's about to say come on we're trying
to we're trying to get clever here
all right are there stairs up to oh he
came down he came
okay we got two loyalist Rangers in
there
got this guy over here he's outside I
think we're gonna have to go for him
first
oh don't slip
no
see me oh I'm done done
I still don't think they see me yet
oh that was a red one you can't block
those
foreign
all right buddy I've had enough of you
got rid of that one you've never seen a
wizard
music like you
leviosos
there we go
of course yeah there's a lot more now
oh wait you guys didn't know I was here
all right he's got the red shield so you
have to cast a red spell
let's do a Let's do an ancient magic
attack right there
oh
I'm telling you man when as you get
better at the combat it's so satisfying
it's so satisfying we're on normal
difficulty good question I've actually
thought about bumping it up to hard
though
I haven't died I think I've died like
one time maybe dude I think this might
be it I think this might be it
no no no you don't see me yet I think
this might be how we get in there
the part that I'm still
I need a little more practice at is is
like switching between all these so
I'm not gonna say how you do it but you
do not start off with all four slots of
the diamond here in the bottom you do
not start off with all four of them you
just start off with one so you can only
map four Spells at a time so they really
like the progression is really nice you
don't just immediately start with all of
them so we're gonna try to go back to
stealth
let's make sure we didn't miss any oh
yeah there's still some over there and
the trolls I forgot about the trolls
so we might just be able to sneak by
these guys
and maybe take care of the trolls later
I just want to get into that part
oh don't look over here
turn the other way
I'm also thinking about disabling those
uh dueling feet pop-ups
I'm all about like the immersion just
taking the HUD oh he he's not playing
around dude he's just locked in right on
the spot
right but you do come on get back you do
more damage
here's what we're gonna do we're gonna
do a delicious
he's got purple
but Stupify will go through anything
which is really nice so the way you cast
Stupify is he's one last follower ran
Rock when you do that
Patrick with another 10 gifteds
Patrick oh my goodness
Patrick thank you so much for what is
that 30 40
gifted memberships from Patrick tonight
oh my goodness Patrick thank you so much
guys if you just got a gift of
membership make sure you think Patrick
you get access to all of our fun
Wizarding World themed Emoji in the chat
and you also
get a special role in the Discord
exclamation point Discord if you guys
aren't a part of that yet oh we just
unlocked a new collection item damage a
frozen enemy launched an enemy into
another with the pulso and then launch
an enemy into a destructible object with
the pole so
oh I feel like we can set that up
what is that
I feel like we can set that up okay
there's a destructible object over there
oh dude and then more of those little
things too
[Music]
oh the trolls here
oh no he's level 24.
and that did not damage him very much
oh come on
why doesn't Expelliarmus work on me
maybe I have to be higher level or
something
what where did he come from
get me out of here
where did that one come from dude
oh my gosh
the camera's freaking out
foreign
oh Benjamin was not kidding
please
yeah and Cindy I'm too far away maybe at
the pulso
like it's doing a little bit
oh no
love yourself
instantly
like we're not even close man these are
armored trolls I wonder if we can pull
the armor off of them run for his run
dude I can't get wait where did he come
from
no
people say in the game is too easy they
should take them to this area man
which I probably shouldn't even be here
can I pull his armor off
oh wait you know what I've forgotten
about guys
dude is it Mandrake time
like let's see do mandrix actually
do they affect trolls though and we also
have three venomous tentaculas we can
use tenacious and tacula that when
deployed shoot asset at nearby enemies
venomous spectacular seeds can be
purchased at dog wheat and death cap
must be grown in large pots
all right I feel like we're I feel like
I'm gonna get back in here
uh excuse me
try to Dash
all right we're about to find out dude
we're about to find out
mandrakes
let's go Mandrake so
are they stuck oh that'd be great if you
guys got stuck all right mandrakes
first Dodge that didn't dodge that and
now
mandrakes go
let's go man drinks for the win that
didn't last very long though that did
not last very long
okay wait I think if we Dodge three
times
one
I'm just trying okay incendio does
pretty well
oh I should have blocked that I could
have done a speaker all right
a little bit too far
incendio is like a very close range one
guys very close range
I feel like we need to stick to the red
spells on these glazius does pretty well
if you want to just like
spell the office
here we go ancient Magic
okay that did pretty well that did
pretty well
see I'm telling you I'm persistent we're
gonna stick with this venomous
stentacula go to work go to work
the Vietnam just hit me
oh that was so
Frozen right before the spill
Ed
okay I should focus on this troll
because he's almost down
foreign
I feel like you should be able to rip
their armor off
you lost this club
oh wait now we got you here oh no quite
no way dude
okay we need to cast I'm telling you man
there's so much going on there's so much
going on
no
all right I just need you I I just need
to get rid of the little guys all right
he's done four now he's scared because I
used ancient Magic
he just doesn't know what hit him
roll
away from you
okay now let's cast Leviosa on you roll
away from you
also
all right troll just me and you buddy
just me and you now
come on do it do it no not that one not
that one come on do the big slam that
one yep there you go
what that barely stunned you at all
right
okay I need to be using glacias more
imagine if I died now after all that
imagine
I'd be so mad okay he is stunned
this one is has so much help and he's
level 22. that's what I am
okay ready
all right collect ancient magic collect
it collect it collect it now we're ready
all right that was pretty good that was
pretty good
incentive
now what I meant to do still learning
still learning
oh we almost got you now buddy
he almost got you now
oh no
I don't want to get too cocky here don't
want to get too cocky where we totally
finish him off here
he's like yeah I know which attack you
want me to do I'm not gonna do it
just not gonna do it
there it is
oh of course yes
let's go dude
get those trolls out of here get them
out
just just get them out of my game
all right that was fun dude that was fun
that was fun
yeah this is normal they were so I'm
level 22 that last troll
was also level 22 but then the other one
was level 24.
now
another tip for you guys I said we're
gonna try to try to give some tips here
I should have done this before
but if I go into the collections here so
if you don't want to know
if you don't want to know all of the
enemies in the game actually I only have
look at that that's crazy I don't even
have half of them yet 30 out of 69 High
drives for a second Hydra is in three
two one
because I want to go through here and
I'm going to read
okay you can open your eyes now you can
open your eyes it's not really showing
the wolf you knew the wolf was in the
game but right here so this mountain
troll the trolls forehand backhand Club
swing pattern attacks will break through
common Shield charms dodging is the
safest Choice distance will not protect
as we've learned we've learned
against an angry troll as it will tear
up chunks of Earth and throw them at its
targets after the troll slams its oh
this was an armor troll this might be
different
I think it is different
I think it's
oh don't look don't look
hold on I have to go up I have to go up
if you don't want to know the enemy
okay that was a fortified troll
yeah armor troll that's the one we
fought okay same deal at the beginning
uh breakthrough Comet Shield charms
dodging is the safest defense distance
will not protect yep yep yep after the
troll slams its clubs on the ground with
both hands flipping it upward with flip
flopindo
foreign
not have unlocked yet we'll have greater
leverage than usual sending the club
into the Troll's face for a powerful
blow all the enemies have stuff like
this guys
all the enemies have stuff like that
hitting control with its own Boulder
will catch it off guard and make it more
vulnerable to follow-up attacks was one
of them fortified okay that was this guy
then
uh same deal same deal though after he
slams Club on the ground with both hands
flipping It Forward upward
with fopindo we'll have glare
if I can't speak I can't speak
greater leverage than usual sending the
club into the Troll's phase all right
well that was cool that was epic
hopefully this unlocked
what's this yes
troll boogies
hopefully this unlocked uh what we were
hoping for
let's find out
so the whole purpose ladies and
gentlemen
the whole purpose for us doing that
you just got sick Patrick
troll bogeys I know
because we wanted to see
if this oh I think this might be it guys
we want to get into here and we want to
unlock the rest of the map
and then when we finally get this we're
gonna we're gonna put it on a timer and
we're gonna see how long it takes to
just fly completely across the map
we are I don't know how many hours into
the stream because our stream messed up
from the beginning
it started and then it stopped and then
yeah it was weird
what happens when you don't listen
all right all right all right here we go
here we go
you're just tuning in guys this is not
Story related the stuff you're seeing
now
it's just a random
I don't even know what it is like an
enemy stronghold that we found we're
trying to get through here this is the
closest we've been so far I think this
might be it
these are high level guys they're 22
which is what I am right now we've got a
high level Commander
or loyalist commander and then loyalist
Warrior
and then we're gonna have more up there
okay I think can we get this guy without
the other one seen yes
that's good we're not gonna alert them
just yet
all right thank you for your gold sir
glacias didn't Encino yeah as I was in
that fight I remembered
I remember reading about glacias when
they're frozen you get get some extra
damage
yeah good call
12 a.m oh man you guys got what an hour
us U.S folks an hour to go man
an hour to go then everybody watching
live
everybody watching live is gonna be out
of here you know what I don't blame you
I don't blame you it's an awesome game
all right so we got two kind of back to
back here we might have to
break our cover right here
just walk very slowly
I love how the character whiskers
oh did you see him
the Katie ain't happy
I don't think I got enough cover here he
might be the last man
oh there's nothing up there
14 hours oh yeah yeah peace pc yeah PC
folks will be hanging out
oh
yes redorean yes yes
that was a good move that was a good
move I'm glad glad Avalanche and WB were
able to make that happen for PC folks I
guess there's still no way for epic to
preload but I know on Steam you can
pre-load
dude he went right to where that guy was
the other one's hanging back
all right he's done now
I want to get to him before he's in the
sight
there's that other guy
there's the flu Flame
okay wait is he facing no he's facing
the other way
ah
all right definitely hitting this
because we spent so much time trying to
get here prove dangerous if I'm not
careful
all right that's going to be
confringo
I love how he whispers confringo even
though
it's a super loud spell
revenues
all right rocks are cleared
hear more goblins
all right I think we can come out of
stealths
for now
guys thank you for all the new
subscribers by the way welcome very much
appreciated hope you guys are enjoying
the stream uh we've been covering this
game for a while we have a lot of videos
up on it including a brand new one today
which is all about our impressions of
the first 20 hours of the game
I have really been enjoying it so far
oh I missed that little bag
probably some
wait where is it do we need to destroy
oh
revelio what
see I think I don't have bombarded yet
I'm wondering if there's gonna be more
stuff we can destroy
because bombarda is gonna be more
powerful
uh no no story we're not showing any
story stuff good question good question
soundtrack good night thank you for
being here and stopping by
yeah thank you guys for uh for bearing
with me
we had a
Rocky start to the stream it wasn't
showing or no it it totally died on us
stream died and it we were playing
Ratchet and Clank for a second
so we really appreciate you guys
refreshing and and staying with me
all right so I yeah I don't I don't
think I have anything to get that right
now
although hold on I don't think I tried
to pulso and I've
[Music]
think you're gonna have to
get into there with bombarda maybe
they're on
all right that's fine though there's
still a lot here that we can do so we
unlocked
which flu flame was it okay perfect it
was this flu flame all right
we're getting there we're getting there
see the problem is I feel like even when
we unlock this over here
I know what we can do though what we can
do to get around it so our goal chat our
goal is we're gonna start we're gonna
get all the way down here if we can I
have no idea I mean this looks like some
very Rocky terrain here as well I'm
hoping once we get through this wall
right here it's like the Night's Watch
or guarding this dude that's how they're
keeping this wall really secure but we
got through
I'm hoping once you get through then we
can just fly on the Broom but if all of
this stuff up here
if you have to travel on foot for all
this I don't think we're gonna be able
to do it tonight
so it's kind of hard to tell with the
terrain some of it looks like you can
fly over
but if not if not we will time it we'll
time it from right here and go all the
way to the top we'll do that
no dragon I have not learned AK yet I
have not I haven't even haven't had the
option to learn it yet
yeah Ben I think that's I think that's
fine we'll show that later
yeah I don't feel like hogsmead or the
castle is a big spoiler we won't show
everything in the castle because I feel
like there's just some stuff people need
should experience I mean
I feel like you should experience on
your own tomorrow this is just tonight
guys so tonight
this has been a stream in the works in
the making for a very very long time I
wanted to do right by by you guys who
supported us and we had promised you
know this was going to be a countdown
stream we were counting down to midnight
and when we when we plan that we didn't
know that we would be fortunate enough
to get an early copy from WB but
since we did I just didn't think it made
sense not not to stream some of it so
yeah we're kind of going for a little
half step of just tonight is just about
exploring
doing open World stuff
but then tomorrow tomorrow we'll be
going live in the morning on Twitch
Wednesday we're back on YouTube see
originally I was planning it was going
to be all YouTube Some people were
complaining about that today they're
like come on I thought
I don't want to do two platforms I had
planned to do all YouTube however
Hogwarts Legacy is doing some official
drops for the game which means there's
gonna be some uh in-game Cosmetics you
can earn by watching people on Twitch
one of them the Merlin cosmetic which
looks Fire by the way you have to watch
their official stream
which is tomorrow at 11 11 A.M eastern
time we but then there's a couple of
other oh no The Rock there's a couple of
other drops they're going to be doing
and and you can watch any streamer that
has drops enabled and is playing
Hogwarts Legacy so we plan Wizards we'll
have no choice but to submit to us
commit to us
okay he's got his back turned
oh man this this Goblin right here dude
he's gonna I think he's gonna fall
oh he he fell but not the way I thought
he was gonna fall forward
dude this area is crazy
okay that's another chest right there
rugged fedora
one interesting note they did end up
changing all the currency
so in the state of play we saw that they
had Galleon sickles and canuts
but it seems like you only it's just
only galleons
I haven't gotten anything else yet all
right I don't think there's any Revenue
oh there's another one right there all
right let's take these out and then I'm
pretty sure we can break into that right
there
oh he's looking right at me no no no no
no
trying to go stealth here turn around
dude
now you can do this watch let's see if
this works
who is he
oh I wish there was something I could
like throw you can get him to go
investigate
yeah I think we're just gonna have to
I think we're just gonna have to go
crazy let's do it
oh no though Guys these are level 25 man
see if that takes him out
okay so it does all right that's good
oh this is like a boss
and the boss
did we just take him out
you're purple
inside here
I love some of the dialogue dude
it seems before you were born
Rebellion I did not mean right there all
right we got him your blood's on Round
Rock's hands
welcome guys welcome to the new
subscribers thank you thank you
not sure if you get Early Access though
not seeing it
yeah yeah oh for uh for the twitch drops
tomorrow yeah yeah I think it's like 20
minutes oh okay here's it we this is our
first time having an item like this
let's talk about these so we're keeping
things relatively spoiler free guys on
the stream tonight no Story related
stuff
um but we have been talking about just
some of the basics of the game if you
have any questions
let me know I'll try and answer them
um wait what was that item see I was
talking too much I forgot right here
okay
so you're gonna come across these items
which not a lot at least not yet to me
not too frequently that they're
unidentified
and so once you unlock the room of
requirement there is a
an area there
where you can take them and it will
identify for you it'll give you the
stats of the gear and also if there's
like a special perk on the gear
so that's what this unidentified means
so I cannot equip that yet right now
which we could change up uh change up
our attire here in a little bit too
yeah no problem jmac no problem
definitely wanted to make tonight still
fun for people counting down to the game
the official info page oh if you're
trying to post a link
it might not let you post the link uh
Luis
released for the Mountain Time Zone oh
gosh don't do this to me
it would be so it's midnight Eastern 11
Central it would be 10 yeah 10 Mountain
Time
my wand specs yeah sure so the wand
this is what we got for our wand
all this was brought over from
Wizarding World this these you unlock in
game
and if you are thinking oh that doesn't
look like too many wand handles there
let me show you this
if you go into your collections page
I only have eight out of 42. 8 out of 42
wand handles
so I'm that was totally a surprise I
didn't know anything about that people
have been I knew people have been asking
for it I knew man I was like there's
there's got to be a way that they can
work one customization into the game
what is that
it's just a light don't panic
dude you know what I first thought it
was
I thought it was at first
you know the dummies from The Haunted
hogsmead shop which I have not seen I've
not done that yet
I thought it was them like hanging
upside down like just the Torso
I thought they were just hanging upside
down I'm like oh wait no it's just a
light Don't Panic we're good here we're
good
so that's that's the extent of the one
on customization right there coasting
along hello trophy hello
so the extent of the want customization
I'm not going to spoil the actual wand
ceremony but when you do the wand
ceremony you have some customization
there rebellio
I hear a page
I knew I heard a page
antique Compass unfortunately the fact
that this antique muggle Compass was
dropped here means the Muggle who
dropped it is probably wandering through
whales by now
so yeah there's some stuff you can tweak
with the wand when you first get it
and as far as I know that once you do
that that is set so that's like
oh Indigo sorcerer that sounds cool so
that applies to like watch this if I
just take off the handle like this is
what you first get when you first do
your one so all of this like
discoloration this this design
all of this that was done during the
wand ceremony
all of this you're gonna find and unlock
these throughout the game
so we'll go ahead and put that handle
that's my favorite handle so far just
kind of kind of simple but elegant at
the same time
play with no map honestly that's just up
I mean that's up to you I'll show you
guys what it looks like with it turned
on
so if I go in here and I show the mini
map
so there you can see like I I probably
once I beat the game and I just want to
like go through collect stuff
I probably will turn it on because I
think it's it's useful to see however I
do have disabled the the little yellow I
disabled that too on the mini map
I just like honestly like I'm I'll tell
you guys regulars of the stream know I'm
terrible directions terrible terrible
terrible
Mr Moe with the five
Mr Moe what is up dude retro not
sticking around patiently waiting for my
time to pledge just wanted to say much
love to you and house rack and tour
being a heck of a ride it has indeed Mr
Moe it has indeed thank you so much for
the five dude enjoy the game enjoy the
game I don't know if you're on PC or if
you're on Console you don't have much
longer to go
you do not have much longer to go but if
you're on PC a few more hours a few more
hours
so yeah it's just totally a personal
preference me even somebody terrible at
directions though
I'm gonna stretch for a second actually
I haven't had any trouble at all with
the one or with the uh with the map
having it disabled anytime I need to get
somewhere I'll just mark it
and then I push up on the d-pad
and you get this little Golden Trail
right here which will lead you where you
need to go but what I'm just exploring
what I do is I'll keep on the uh
like watch this if I Mark something just
right in front of me here
I don't know let's actually let's just
like Mark that blue flame
and then I could kind of at least see
the icon so I know the the general
vicinity of it which this one is really
strange really really strange
but yeah so it's totally personal
preference
for me though I'm like honestly
I first tried to disable the Spells too
that was too hard though that was too
hard I feel like you need the Spells I
might actually be able to get by
without the health and ancient magic
meter actually you know what let's just
try it why not
I am all about like minimal minimal
minimal HUD elements and you can see I
mean they give you
they give you all the options here
damage numbers yep we turned that off
um the tool wheel HUD oh my goodness so
this one is
normally by default that you also get
that little L1 over there but I don't
like I just hold L1 and you could just
pull this up and then you know whatever
you've selected
that's what you'll use
so I have that one disabled too
wheel HUD off
and then let's see health and ancient
magic yeah let's try to turn that off
let's see if we can do it without that
and then we just turn the minimap off
again and then spells spells you got to
keep I'm hoping what I would love to see
is if they had it added like an auto
hide so like right now while I'm just
walking
it'd be great if there was no HUD at all
just just no HUD and then like I pull up
my wand and start doing battle then the
HUD appears I think that'd be really
cool
really cool
and help with just like the overall
immersion
somebody was asking about once like
hiding the wands
or like putting them away it's automatic
so like right now you see I'm casting a
few spells the wand is out and then if I
just don't move around for a bit
doesn't take too long they just kind of
pocket IT pocket it away
and now I'm running freely and I'll keep
running without the wand until I press
R2 again
and then it pops back out I don't know
actually if I if I run let's see do they
put it away oh there's an enemy over
there didn't know that
yes I guess if you run they will not put
it away
but then if you just stop
after a few seconds
there you go put it away
yeah exactly like I mentioned the video
I think that'd be awesome
yeah Jin yeah you you can hide the spell
the Spells yep it's just like really
difficult especially once you like right
when you first start and you only have
those like four spells
it's not bad because you can remember
like okay
square is my levioso X is my accio
triangle to pulso Circle incendio but
then when you unlock this one this one
and this one
I just can't keep up I can't keep up and
remember like which one is which when I
can't see it
but now the health I'm pretty sure when
you're really low Health the whole
screen kind of turns turns red
and you know what I honestly don't even
want these uh
let's turn off that that flu flame right
here
this one here
and if for some reason it's marking this
uh let's go to I think this is in
hogsmead I'm gonna
unmark you
you no wait I want to turn oh I have to
go into the quest it's fine I'm not
gonna worry about it I don't want to go
into the quest because I don't oh wait
no
it didn't
maybe it didn't mark it now
oh there was like two that's what was
going on
there we go
there were see now it turns that icon
off
I was like why is that there were two
icons kind of right there
on top of each other yeah dude we are
really far from Hogwarts this has been
our goal basically of the whole stream
we were trying to see how far south we
could get on the map and it looks like
now we can travel by broom again which I
am very excited for
because hopefully that means we can fly
all the way to this bottom section here
this is the one
I'm gonna Mark that
that's the one I want to go for
we're just right here dude we're right
here
because what we're going to try to do
let's see if we can finish this before
midnight when a lot of people are going
to be getting to play the game
I want to basically try and go the full
length of the map
and see how long it takes I'm sure
someone out there has already done this
I don't care
I do not care I want to do it
I want to do it
it's like the one thing I told my moms
before the stream I was like that would
be like a fun goal something fun to show
off on stream
now look now the challenge here guys is
don't get sidetracked
not to get sidetracked
all this stuff around looks so cool
all right this is good though this is a
good sign I feel like we're gonna be
able to just fly to it
now large and open is the world
that's what we're trying to find out
because everybody people just look at
the map but maps are really hard to
judge because
you need oh look at that look at that
dude you need context for the map and if
you don't have context it's like what's
the point you know
so earlier in the Stream I showed I
zoomed in on Hogwarts I was like look
that's how big Hogwarts is
and just to show you guys who weren't
here earlier look at this look at this
I'm gonna go all the way up here so
you're thinking okay maybe this if I
zoom out
it's like all right well from here to
here maybe that looks kind of small but
then you think about everything you've
seen from Hogwarts
this is Hogwarts right here
this is Hogwarts so every everything
about the castle everything around
quidditch pitch like
it's right there that's how big it is
when you zoom out
and then you have all this other stuff
all this other stuff too
all right so we got that
I've got those balloons
all right we're going in we're going in
let's do this
information without context is virtually
meaningless
indeed indeed
Quest can be tracked yeah
I don't know why I guess it's thinking
I'm lost
the game's like you're you're way off
from where you need to be sir
and to be honest with everything you can
toggle and turn off you can probably
turn that off too
like see like
I'm so tempted I'm so tempted we're
gonna stick to our goal though stick to
our goal
and see once I get here
and once I unlock this flu flame you
know what that's something else I should
have been looking for along the way yeah
we're literally like flying right over
flu flames
actually you know what let's mark that
one first
we'll hit that one first and then
get to that one over there which I'm
kind of worried about this Terrain
looks like we might hit another uh
Mountain
thoughts on the game so far and I I love
it I love it and I've been covering it
for a long time
and had a feeling it would be good
you know it's just hard to know how how
good a game will be until you actually
oh wait not that one so you actually
have it in your hands
and when we went out to that preview
event and I got the hands on with it
I knew right away from that at the very
least I was like it plays well it
controls well at the very least
then it's just all about you know the
variety is it fun to to do the upgrades
and to go through the missions I should
investigate oh let's investigate and I
think that's all Dylan edits in the
house Dylan what is up dude one of the
OG
Hogwarts Legacy creators Dylan's uh I
think Dylan's like full-time video
editor now I've seen some of the edits
he works on awesome but Dylan had a back
like dude when we were first
it was when Hogwarts Legacy was official
but I remember watching some of Dylan's
videos you may have known him under the
name of Knox n-o-x was the channel name
Dylan hope you're doing well dude thanks
for stopping by we're just we're just
having some fun here streaming some
non-story related items
and I saw L1 posting about the like
button guys thank you all so much thank
you all so much for the likes it really
does help man we had a our first stream
we started tonight on YouTube we had
like 700 people there the whole stream
crashed
no idea why so like all those likes and
everything they're just
gone
they're just gone and then our stream
came back up and it said we were playing
Ratchet and Clank I kid you not I kid
you not chat people who've been here the
whole time can tell you
I I don't know dude I don't know it was
the weirdest thing this looks like an
accio cast right here
woo here we go oh man I did it I got
sidetracked you guys
hold on I think this one is legit though
I think it's legit because I think
I think we have to go through this
little cave area to get to this blue
flame all right so you can't you can't
get upset with me for going to this one
million in the house right now let's go
one million in a house
dude one million people hit that like
button we'll be zooming we'll be zooming
let me tell you
all right so
I'm trying to get over
when already broken pot
repair
oh it was worth a try right
repair was probably the one that right
now it's it's really
there's very specific things you can
pero
at least from what I found so far
okay yeah I always think you can light
these things but you never can
oh okay this is all about accio right
here oh the inferious and it's a level
25.
we're not supposed to be here you
are usually distracted no we're going
for this blue flame
oh shall we also have an ancient magic
hot spot in here let's go
I'm not going to show you those I'm not
gonna show those for I mean they're
they're not too spoilery but
still we'll avoid it
oh you know what this actually might be
on the outside though
level 25 I am level I think I'm still 20
I'm 23 now okay 23 23.
can we petrifice you
does that finish him off though
oh let's go
terrific is totalus ladies and gentlemen
most OP spell in the game Revenue
oh
uh yes we see you there
Dev said if you can skip an enemy do it
way to kill everything just cause
hey we had to get through a pretty rough
section to even get up here
all right so spider there for that loot
no no spider for the big chest
and yeah I was totally wrong so it looks
like this area is not how you
get to that flu flame so chat you were
right I totally derailed and got
sidetracked
all right so let's see are there any
clues they're blue ones okay I'm
guessing that we just pull the blue
oh dude that is oh no no no no no no
the way he was moving his legs in there
open sesame
they're all gonna open aren't they
I'm calling it dude they're all gonna
open
maybe not oh you know those spiders are
coming out though too everybody oh
they're coming out
oh opulence spiders web hat
your gear slots are full okay that's not
good especially not while we're out this
far traveling
I bet that one is an upgrade though
it is all right let's first let's take
our hood off
is I want to see
look at that hat man does not go at all
I want to see what this one looks like
oh that's kind of cool
that's kind of cool and it is officially
our most powerful
all right so we were given some tips
earlier guys you can destroy or sell
items
and still keep it as an appearance so
it's very important when you start
playing the game you you figure out the
menu and the difference between an
appearance versus the actual piece of
gear because in some ways they look the
same
so let's take for example let me just
find my lowest level thing right here so
let's see that is
149
152 yeah so I think this green one right
here is my lowest level okay so it is
the rugged Fedora so if you put it on
that's what it looks like
I'm gonna go ahead and put on the
opulent spider though and then I'm going
to press L3 to destroy just because I
don't want to travel anywhere and sell
right now
so I'm gonna destroy it again it's
called the rugged fedora
so he destroyed it it's gone it's out of
our gear
but if now I go to my hat
I don't push X to change the hat but I
can push Square to change appearance you
see that at the bottom there I don't
think I have anything blocking it okay
good yeah nothing blocking it
change appearance and now
let's see
there it is rugged fedora
so it still shows up as an appearance I
have not yet found any limit to the
appearances so I'm guessing that you can
I'm guessing you can just like I don't
think there's a cap for these
huh no pun intended
I don't think there's I don't think
there's a cap I think you can have as
many as you need
at least I haven't found found uh hit
that hit the limit yet so like right now
what was actually on it was the opulent
spiders hat yeah
but I am going to turn it off you can
just do invisible headwears if you're
like I don't want to wear any hat
and then I'm going to go back in and put
my hood up here
somebody was asking about
um
[Music]
oh there was a yeah it's a transmog
exactly
it's just full-on transmog like you can
you can literally look like anything
you've ever collected and you keep the
stats which I know here let me
hide my cam for a second star Geezer Tim
Tim what is up my friend in the house
Tim thank you so much for the gifted
memberships
you guys have been crazy with the gift
of memberships tonight
Tim one of our moderators here and in
the Discord Tim are you counting it down
dude
are you counting it down
I don't think I know what system you're
playing on Tim
so there you go you guys can see the uh
overall offense defense Health number
there
let me pull the chat back up there it is
ah
yeah this so the robe
is the dark arts robe
the
I think that's the only dark arts thing
I'm wearing actually it looks like the
main outfit is but the main outfit is
actually one that I've unlocked called
legendary armored attire the actually
dark are dark arts one is this one right
here dark arts ensemble
is The Game worth getting uh I'm loving
it I mean it depends on how much money
you have you know like if you if you
have the disposable income and you think
it looks cool sure go ahead and buy it
now
but if you're like eh I don't really
have the money right now rather wait for
a sale buy use you know
that's fine too but I'm like I'm a huge
fan of the Wizarding World and I've just
I've been having a blast with it
been having a blast yeah
so uh we got an early copy from WB for
those of you asking how are we playing
and we're just doing non-story stuff
non-story related
we're all the way up
I mean we are deep deep into the
southern portion of this map we're
trying to unlock this flu flame right
here but I'm really close to this
ancient magic hot spot
and we also have some spiders in here so
sorry guys Rebellion
I hear the ancient magic hot spot but
like what happens
it's got presents of course if you mess
up
if you mess up you get the spiders
all right spider
oh my gosh that just took him out
instantly
all right but you know what it's fine
because I wanted to get the loot anyway
wanted to get the loot anyway all right
now we got to do it on this one
show yourself
always a little bit bigger he's bigger
Thorn back all right let's see what
ancient magic attack would get oh this
is my favorite one
that's my favorite one with the spider
you're a deadly great spider I lost my
mind the first time that happened dude
lost my mind yeah fire is really really
strong against them
all right was there anything in here or
no I just
I just like took him out for the heck
just took him out for the heck of it
all right so I think we've done
everything we can do here
all right so back to the goal what time
is it 11 30. all right we got half an
hour half an hour before the console U.S
launch of Hogwarts Legacy to my New
Zealand friends to my UK friends
on Console hope you guys are enjoying
the game you're probably not here
watching the stream right now if you are
and to my PC friends
remain remain strong remain strong
don't have much longer to go
we will help you pass the time oh yeah
of course looks like all we needed to do
is just fly around the edge here
welcome to all the new Subs by the way
guys thank you thank you
good to have you here
all right let's go ahead and destroy
this last one
and then we're gonna go down here
perfect
this is a nice little game design thing
I love that you don't have to
oh man hold on you may have to for this
one
oh because it's inside if it wasn't
inside I love a little game design thing
they had is that you could fly right
next to the flu flame and you'll still
get it what the oh my gosh you scared me
ignatia
you scared me
Tater with a super jet Tater what's up
still have a pre-downloaded because I've
been sick and busy with work hopefully
it won't take too long are you on uh
are you on PS5 or I mean really it
doesn't matter it's all about your
internet connection
no you could do it you could do it CAD
Bane Bounty Hunter what's up man all
sorts of uh
seeing so many of you guys in the Stream
tonight man it's awesome Epic Level gasp
that was so awesome and hilarious with
the spider right
right favorite ancient magic attack so
far
it's like you're you're just not
expecting it the first time because you
feel I mean they they show before you
know before launch they'd shown us quite
a few of the at least we thought
quite a few of the ancient magic attacks
but maybe they didn't show us as many as
we go
the jump scare right
oh dude clagmark Castle
there's like zero chance we don't get
distracted by the clagmar castle so I'm
gonna set this first I'm gonna set this
first
all right here we go
I need to turn that off down there Quest
can be tracked I know they can be
tracked dude it's still a thousand I
don't know is that that's probably
meters away
longest 30 minutes of your life Jimmy
Jimmy that's exactly what we're trying
to figure out like like actually time it
actually time it is what we're trying to
do but what we discovered is there was
this area that was not locked off I
could get there but it was just a lot of
high level enemies
oh see I want to go down there I want to
explore that right there
dude I feel like it has been night
forever when does the sun come up around
here
is that water below oh yeah it is it is
it is
oh this will actually give me a good
chance
Chad's like oh here he goes again
I'm telling you you wait you wait if
you're not playing it yet wait you'll
see but I wanted to show you guys
something cool with the broom I promise
that's all it is I promise that's all it
is watch okay so we're gonna we're gonna
drop in the water
now watch this stuff watch this
you can steal you can immediately hop on
the Broom for the water
so some people were asking earlier can
you like uh fall off like fall off your
broom from way up here no but you can
jump into the water and then immediately
pop out onto the broom
we are waiting we are waiting there you
go there it is
all right so now we're going we're going
we're going for the flu flame at the
very edge of the map
after we destroy these balloons
there's uh there's something in
open world games
I've talked about this before Luke
Stevens had a really good video on this
but apparently when CD projekt Red was
working on The Witcher 3
I think it was the 32nd
30 second rule 22nd rule 40 second rule
there was there was it's I think it was
30 like the 30 second rule they called
it
to where
they would basically have it to where
every 30 seconds you should be able to
walk in a Direction
and if you don't encounter something
within that 30 seconds then something
needs to be added like whether it's a
point of Interest whether it's a little
like Bandit Camp whether it's like
enemies that attack you whether it's a
treasure like every 30 seconds there
should be something so I'm I'd love to
test that out later
with this game because I I feel like I
feel like it is dude because I just I'm
I'm constantly
finding other things
benefit of popping balloons XP that
means Marlin trial indeed
wait that was a dog bog level 30 no sir
no sir I really wanted to go and like
get a screenshot though
can you do you mind Doug bog like can I
I'm gonna reveal you right here you
don't see me you you do not see me go on
go on about your day
yep yep that's better just go on just go
on
oh no
okay he didn't turn around
oh I just wanted to get a
wanted to get a shot of this man
but first we must not get sidetracked
we've came all this way
we've came all this way for the flu
flame we will activate this flu Flame
and then we're gonna do it man I think
we can do it I think we can now go the
full length of the map when we get to
that one area handy resource indeed your
Field Guide I mostly I mean my guess is
that you can't fly that area
what
for people to help me there was a dude
in there
well hello sir
Cillian Hawksworth how are you sir
everything all right oh dude
I wondered I don't think I would ask for
help by spiders from someone like that
if you've got some wigs I'm sure that
would put me right silly and dude trying
to get my Wigan wheel potion
I'll help you I've run out or
[Music]
yeah she
I really want to say you don't need it
you like him drew that was my my
eight-year-old and four-year-old I was
like guys what do you like the best
showed him all the items I had
a flesh Moon all right even despite my
my look here I am playing as good
so I'll help you I do have some Wicked
spiders do tend to appear in Ruins hey I
have enough to spare stay away from them
that's right you tell them saved me life
oh I can never repay you yes yes I shall
stay away from them you'll see must stay
away from ruins with spiders everyone's
with spiders
I'm hoping they'll add one Draco oh dude
look he he accept this token of my
appreciation you had a Maxima potion
wait what hold on what does the Maxima
potion do
oh it increases spell damage okay all
right I was about to say
I was like if that's just like a
stronger wig and weld why did you need
mine all right okay all right you're
cool dude you're cool thank you
appreciate that
oh and it's sunrise
yeah they really need to add the photo
mode for sure for sure for sure
and that's something that devs can add
are you serious oh I was I wasn't I
wasn't invisible but you know what
here's what we do we're gonna see how
far south we can go
so we're at the edge of the map guys
I mean we're at the edge of the map I
actually I I guess I guess you might be
able to go
okay there it is there's the Golden
Barrier
so that that's the edge of the map right
here on the southern side
and we're just going to follow it all
the way down
to right I feel like right here is going
to be the absolute
oh it's not even letting me Mark over
here so yeah I feel like right there is
the absolute furthest pretty close to
that
Tater with another Super Chad thank you
so much Tater does your version have the
day one patch it does not
it does not it did have a patch during
our review period for it however I don't
think it's the day one patch somebody in
chat was saying that it's not it's not
uh the day one patch is not hitting till
the 10th
I've been like off Twitter for the past
several hours so I don't know
wait why is it like it's marking
Underground
that's fine though we're gonna go ahead
and remove that marker
all right so we're gonna fly till we hit
the Golden Barrier on the southern side
there it is
there it is
all right so here's we're gonna do we're
gonna go all the way up
as high as it will let us go up
and then we had another supersack
Christy Jean
what is up Christy thank you for the
Super Chat another one of our moderators
here so that power nap didn't happen I
got distracted
no you didn't get your nap Christy
you were trying to nap before before the
game came out right
go to the castle I'm tempted but I want
to time this I want to time this so
all right people love the internet here
we go we are at the southernmost tip I
mean as far south as you can go in
Hogwarts Legacy and we just it took us a
while but we got here and we are going
to time how long it takes to go buy
broomstick from the south here all the
way
to the very top of the North Ford bog
here could we fast travel
we could but we're not going to because
we want to see just how big this map
actually is now here's what's going to
be interesting this part right here when
you get to the coastal Cavern I'm almost
positive that we have to get out on foot
here so we're gonna have to travel on
foot to go through the cavern which that
would be I mean if there's no way to fly
over then that's how anyone would have
to travel but then from there I think
all of this other area over Hogwarts and
then all the way to the north yeah we've
already gotten to that one so I'm pretty
sure all the way up top once we're
through that area I think we're good I
think we are good so here's what I'm
gonna do
no Jax I can't get distracted I cannot
get distracted we have to see it through
I'm gonna mark this one right here
and let's see what it says six thousand
679
I think it's I think it must be meters
all right guys
let me get let me get my stopwatch
let me get my stopwatch
chat chat's just gonna start going crazy
with like to it saying everything they
can
to get me to uh not
go all the way but don't you guys want
to know too I'm curious all right here
we go
I'm starting the troll fight was a good
distraction that's how we that's how we
got in here dude Patrick that's a good
point though
enemies respawn in this game so we're
gonna have to like just immediately get
through that area hop back on our broom
all right three two one all right we
have started the timer and we're off so
right now I'm holding L2 on the Broom
that's the little yellow meter that you
see in the bottom right
and now once it runs out then you have
to wait a little bit you don't get that
speed now I could immediately go ahead
and do it again right now it's just
going to run out faster so I'm gonna
wait
and let it refill again no the balloons
I want to go for the balloons so bad
all right now the other problem here is
I'm really bad at directions so I think
this is not this is not where we need to
go through right here we need to go
around
this is as high if you guys are wanting
me to go higher oh my gosh that skeleton
down there I want to explore that
skeleton
no no no we can't we can't I'm I don't
know if I'm gonna be able to make it
this far guys I don't know if I'm gonna
be able to make it that far
not getting distracted by any of these
points of interest look at that castle
over there on the left
oh man this is hard focus focus
welcome to all the new subscribers guys
thank you all for being here hanging out
as we count down the Hogwarts Legacy if
you are in the US on Console you've got
about 15 minutes
about 15 minutes remaining
before the digital Deluxe goes live oh
no we're getting a barrier okay that's
good that we went left though you guys
can kind of see that shimmering Golden
Barrier on the right for whatever reason
they don't want you
trying to fly over that area
if you're just tuning in guys we are
seeing how no
no no no no no can we go around
yeah there we go okay
oh broom's acting kind of weird
all right we're fine now we're fine
we're fine okay that spot right there
see I need to pull up the map
I I should have turned on the mini map
oh my gosh I should have
oh no do I go left or right
oh it's forcing me down it's forcing me
down
I'm not doing this I don't know what's
happening I think it's weather it's the
wind
it's so windy
chat do I go left or right
left left left all right all right we're
gonna trust the chat we're gonna trust
the chat CAD Bean Bounty Hunter with
another Super Chat you could do this go
retro Go I mean honestly we could
probably
even if I just went halfway I think we'd
be able to
what is this
is this a Quidditch
like
dude that's a is that a quidditch
minigame
was that a quidditch minigame
even if it wasn't a quidditch minigame
that was something that was like an
early
quidditch something there
because it had the Hoops oh no it's
forcing me down again
no no the wind
all right we're good we're good we're
good so here yeah this is this is the
one we have to go through
right here and I'm just gonna try it
I'll see if I can
if we can fly through it that would be
great
dude maybe maybe maybe maybe
okay that's fine that's fine all right
so now we run we run
I could do this little number right here
that's basically gonna lead me to where
I need to go anyway
if we see any enemies we just have to
keep going
I have to keep going cannot engage with
any enemies whatsoever
hey that was the little uh area where we
got the um
other flu Flame the rod forest Run
stop it chat don't try to get me
distracted no no we're not giving up
that you can't
this area right here I believe the only
way is you have to get you have to get
off and run through it all right so now
that we're out right here yes back on
Broom
boom there we go all right let's Center
ourselves
3800 to go oh we're we're doing this man
we're doing this before the
before the midnight launch
where it's it's smooth sailing here guys
smooth sailing from here
no mini map nah we got the chat we got
the chat to be our guide
yeah this is PS5 performance mode
very very smooth very smooth
loading tunnel dude it could be Elijah
but I'm pretty sure they don't have one
to the north
I think I've been able to just I I
haven't been using my
boost like I should be so right now
we're at five and a half minutes guys
five and a half minutes by broom
now it is also worth noting I'll show
you guys at the very end here what level
of broom that I have this is not the
fastest broom but it's also not the
slowest broom
I think I've done one upgrade on the
brooms and just look at the castle
ladies and gentlemen
almost
to Hogwarts Castle there
which we like guys there's so much to do
in Hogwarts alone and we haven't spent a
single minute there tonight
we have not spent a single minute
in the castle on this stream
and I've had a blast I don't know about
you guys hope you guys have enjoyed it
too I've had a blast somebody like an
hour ago asked about
you think it's six minutes somebody's
saying six minutes
somebody asked like an hour ago what the
um
if I could show some Castle stuff I'm so
sorry
it's too easy to get sidetracked all
right we're officially over we're at six
and a half
six and a half and we got about uh right
around 2 000 to go
there's there's a nice shot at the Great
Hall see if I can get get you guys a
nice little uh
nice little flyby of the castle here
trying to keep the camera steady it's
easier said than done
all right now my my concern is that's a
little bit of a mountain right there
so I'm hoping we don't hit an invisible
barrier
so that's Passover hogsmeade now
8 45 you think
uh 7 7 13 at the moment you could be
close
all right there's hogsmead
no oh wait it's because it's hogsmeade I
should have remembered
so you can't fly directly over hogsmeade
oh no no no no no no no
all right I think we just gotta get a
little bit lower
why is it okay there we go
come on no Golden Barrier
no Golden Barrier
yes all right we're good we're good
we're good
all right we got it now
we got it now no more golden barriers
and I'm I'm actually don't panic I'm
just gonna completely sail right on by
this
because I want to see how far the map
goes which it it's probably not going to
go too much further north than that that
flame right there
yeah dude I love hogsmeade
I think a 12 looks more like 10.
we're at eight and a half eight and a
half right now
and I've clearly like I've been stopping
and chatting I've clearly not been
purely optimizing for Speed
because every time that yellow meter
refills I should immediately be
fully exhausting it then letting it fill
all the way up again
all right so remember I'm gonna I'm
gonna ignore the uh ignore the flame
and we're gonna keep going
until we hit the Golden Barrier
right there
907 ladies and gentlemen
907 to fully cross the Hogwarts Legacy
map from all the way from the south
let's see go back to our map here
so here we are pretty much at that flu
flame yeah
it was officially 907 and and in terms
of the broom that I had
so I had just a level one upgrade so you
should be able to do it even faster
once you fully upgrade the broom
and people might discover a path that's
that's better than mine about one hour
on foot oh my gosh dude it would take
[Music]
it would take a while on foot
there's the early part of the game you
guys I was I'm not going to give you an
exact
timing
but I was I was a little surprised at
how long it took to
actually get the broom
takes a lot longer than you expect like
I just thought you know the broom will
probably be one of the first things you
just hop out can we I didn't think you
could hop off right here either
I thought you would probably get the
broom within you know the first hour or
so nope nope nope
all right well that was cool we
he's up here too
I want to turn that off what is that
little Quest can be tracked in the track
log
the game is so terrified it's like he
hasn't done any he's not been doing
anything he's got to be bored to death
the game is so afraid that I'm not doing
anything
okay HUD tracking icons no I I like
having those on when I need them
foreign
maybe it's a special notification
show or hide notifications of special
collections
uh rage it
like I don't know I don't know if people
uh
it was more than a few hours I'll say
that I'll say that
it was more than a few hours now be this
being an open world game
maybe there's another way to get a broom
that I don't know about but I don't
think so I think you have to unlock it
first exactly how I did it then you can
buy one in a shop after you do this this
certain Mission you can buy one
you guys think it's special
notifications
it might just be under like standard
five minutes let's go oh my gosh I'm so
excited for you guys
I'm so excited those in the U.S
I just saw your message Nico
Nico Nico said the only thing he needed
was show enemy damage numbers off yeah
that was one of the first things I
turned off
hard mode on if you play a lot of games
I would say go I would say try it I
would say try it you can always turn it
off you can always turn it off
Jay with another Super Chat that Jay
that is an excellent excellent question
and it is the one thing that I have not
yet found a way to turn off
which I'll be honest with you like that
one to me it doesn't bother me I thought
it would I thought it would but in game
when I'm playing like I barely notice it
I I I really barely notice it
but I have not found that one yet in
here or in accessibility so the
accessibility one is here that one's got
some options as well for you
so I first I saw left-handed I was like
what you can put the left one in the
left hand no no it just uh
basically makes the Dual sense
which I don't even think left-handed
people use controller like that
I guess it would make like the d-pad the
face buttons is that right
Milan in the house do you recommend
playing some of the main story quests to
unlock some of the Spells broom Etc
before going a wider explore the map
great great question
great question because I feel like
people will disagree with me on this
I've heard I've listened to so many live
streams and so many people talk about
this game and the first thing they want
to do and the majority of people say
first thing I want to do is just like go
explore I just want to go like I wanna I
wanna fly I want to go all over the
castle
what I would say based on my experience
playing it I mean sure try do that but
if you start to get frustrated just go
do the quests just go do the quest
because you are pretty Limited at the
early part of the game you're pretty
Limited in the Spells you know you're
pretty Limited in that you don't have a
broom
and the only way you're gonna get those
things is by by progressing by
progressing through the story
so I did a little bit of exploring
myself first like look around your
common room look around Hogwarts you'll
start to see some locked doors that you
can't get into yet
um but then when you start going out
into the open world
it's like it's a trek when you're on
foot
it is a Trek
so if you if you ever start feeling like
oh this is kind this is kind of annoying
or if you start to get that little bit
of hint of frustration like uh I don't
want to just run around everywhere
then just go do story missions
and I will say the story missions do a
really good job
they do a really good job of actually
kind of leading you places that you
would want to go check out anyway
I mentioned that in my in my first
impressions too there were a lot of
areas that I ended up going to twice
because I'd already kind of explored and
then my my quests took me there anyway
so that's my advice is do a little bit
of exploring first maybe not as much as
you thought you were going to do but do
a little bit
and then go
then go and do more story Quest missions
Okay so
did we
oh look at this I'm highly allergic in
real life so I will pet you in the game
they're all over Hogwarts too
the cats they're all over Hogwarts one
minute left
ladies and Gentlemen let's go
all right let's count it down people
Draco when it hits like 30 seconds
give me a 30 give me a 30 second in the
chat and we'll 40 says Stephanie all
right all right all right here we go uh
mutton chops dude thank you for the
Super Chat the map size is also
deceiving they're vertical layers yes
also magical portals that take you right
like we saw in the preview in the in the
early uh preview footage good point good
point and yeah there's there there's
some places
if there's some places you are gonna be
going
in the main game as you play through the
story and that maybe don't show up on
the map
15. let's go
let's go ten
nine eight we're way off seven six it's
already 12 a.m on my screen
Hogwarts Legacy has launch
[Music]
let's go ladies and gentlemen
let's go
guys I know a lot of people are going to
be hopping off right now enjoy the game
dude enjoy the game take your time with
it I said that in my early Impressions
take your time don't don't let like the
fomo and like people like telling you
hurry do this do that don't don't let it
get to you is someone making content for
the game I kind of have to
but to you I say take your time don't
rush it enjoy it to those who are
sticking around for a little bit more my
PC folks or anybody if you're going to
be playing on one screen and watch it on
another we'll play for a little bit more
here
play for a little bit more
Dylan
oh my gosh I'm so excited for all you
guys I'm so excited for everybody man
just strike a Red Bull
uh Shayan or shayon very sorry if I
mispronounced that did you already
unlock the Onyx hypogriff no no so dude
I haven't even gotten I haven't gotten
any Beast mounts
I did a beast class but I've not learned
how to like tame
and mount Beast or or the vivariums
all that
haven't done it have it done it we go to
11 with a super chat as well Tristan
here too what is up man
what is up happy see the content doing
well thank you thank you very much
it's good to good to hear from you dude
hope you're doing well
good night good night
only available yeah for deluxe Elijah
right right Deluxe
on Digital hard copy
go camping out at GameStop or something
or I heard somebody was somebody earlier
was doing a uh midnight Midnight launch
oh dude you know what I should
screenshot that that timer
it was 907.
basically 908 we'll round it up
save to photos yeah we tested out guys
how far it would take just to fly all
the way from the bottom of the map to
the top but if someone else made a good
point about the the layers
so we were just purely flying
southernmost Coast to the northernmost
Coast if you are still here anybody
hanging around who's gonna gonna watch
for a bit we are we're not doing story
stuff tonight
although I guess now technically I could
or I mean we could have anyway but I
just wanted to
show love for the people who uh we
promised that we would do like a
countdown stream so
all right well let's take a look I
haven't pulled up my quest log at all oh
this right here I want to see that's why
I went in here let's see what controls
that little pop-up right there is it the
standard notification
no okay so it's not the standard
notification then maybe it is the
special notification
because I want to turn that off if I'm
just exploring
I do not want that popping up
special
yes there it is
there it is special
how long before a PS1 Hagrid mod not
long
not long
oh yeah I love these little plants right
here
lace swing flies
hello dude what's up
he did not like me looking at him did
you hear that grunt
I've always said that travel broadens
the mind
all right I did hear kind of like a
little enemy camp over here a few
sickles
let's see what level these guys are
because they're at the northernmost so
the guys at the southernmost were level
the beasts all the way at the bottom one
level 30. okay these are 23.
and these are the poachers
poacher duelist level 23 all right we
should be fine
especially if we can use stealth on some
of them
level scaling
bro borrow is famous for someone having
a Petro
still nothing I don't think there's no
one maybe there is actually
we'll test that we'll test that we'll go
to an earlier area here in a bit
like right outside the castle
we'll see what they are there live just
long enough to regret it all right let's
see if we can like hit that Barrel over
there
we're gonna do a depulso on it I don't
want to hit the tree though
something's not right here someone
messing about someone messing about
yeah go investigate it
oh no Duty the Duelist is like nah nah
not falling for that
come on go on over there further
you better be a beast
you better be a beast no the quest can
be tracked pop it up again go away
shouldn't be it
yeah
get out of here poachers
all your gear slots are full that's what
we should do
we'll show you guys Hog's meat
we'll show Hogs
collect the money I do not need to have
any of your beverage
all right so
oh but I need to I need to pick this up
I need to know what it is I need to know
foreign
yeah we dominated we dominated those
guys the back to back uh
stealth
all right so we're just gonna destroy
I don't recommend doing this you should
try to sell whenever you can but like
the stuff that's only worth 60. I'm just
gonna destroy that
so now I can pick this up by the way
another tip
if you want to have more gear slots
do Merlin puzzles
do Merlin puzzles do lots and lots of
Merlin puzzles
[Music]
and you will be pleased to see what
happens okay wait
all right we got that revelio is that
all that was over there
there was that like Goblin area too but
let's just go on to hogsmeade
let's go on to hogsmeade
I know the little kitty
all right so hogsmeade map
you can sell at virtually any shop
can sell at any shop
so I'm just gonna do
Let's do let's do Glad racks we'll see
if they have anything new we can buy
um
I've seen so many funny uh
funny GIFs and little uh like tick tocks
and YouTube shorts
did you hear that connect
guys
[Music]
Jake what happened dude what happened
[Music]
new instruments all expensive you know
all the latest visiting world news right
here
man look around Augustus frogs please
refrain from touching
okay all right do I look like I've been
eating chocolate today take your time
oh the snowy owl scarf is an upgrade
all right so basically anything that is
green or blue that is not my highest
tier there's no point in keeping
so we're gonna sell you we're gonna sell
you
and I may even be wrong about the purple
like oh wait these don't have traits
but see it says no trait applied so what
I don't know yet guys what I haven't
figured out is if there's a way for me
to like upgrade like let's say I really
love solar protection spectacles and I
want to upgrade that
I don't know if you can because it has
this no trait applied so clearly I could
apply a trait on it but what's the point
in applying a trait if it's not very
high level
but yeah we're still early still early
cadbane with another Super Chat good
night retro going to bed my pre-order
for the game has been marked ready at
Best Buy
gonna be there when they open at 10 A.M
let's go dude have a good night's sleep
hopefully hopefully we got you uh oh no
don't sell that one
hopefully we help the time pass for you
tonight
in our countdown to launch ladies and
gentlemen
if you are in the U.S and you have
pre-ordered Hogwarts Legacy digital
on Xbox or Playstation you can begin
playing right now like see this one no
trade applied but it's a very low level
foreign
that's good for now
and so then the gear he has for sale
we had an upgrade there and then the
dude all of these are upgrades they're
500.
Kilted Garb that looks as if it was made
for you oh it's it's showing like
underneath
snowy owl scarf
distinguish that looks as if it was made
for you
okay that one's let's go with this one
because it's gonna give us the biggest
boost
Stuart you can in the room of
requirement okay see I knew you could um
you won't be disappointed that's a glad
to act promise
I don't want to
I suspect you have a shop I don't want
to buy anything else you put the
we'll equip the scarf because that's a
solid upgrade
right here
and now we're going to change the
appearance of it
so we're going to change the appearance
to back to this one
you're about all right so now we've
freed up some space in our gear slots
is there a way to know if you've gotten
the skin for something already without
looking at the actual list
you know
I don't think I've gotten
I don't think I've gotten duplicates yet
maybe it's like a smart looting system
I I don't think I've gotten duplicates
of anything
now that you mentioned that
oh wait this one's an upgrade
didn't realize that oh but that one has
the trait though
increase spell damage while concealed by
disillusionment
but see that's like a good example of
maybe you maybe you want to keep the
lower level one
we like that one
yeah I do have I do have the room of
requirement unlocked I just don't have
the um the loom yet
so stuff they've already showed and
talked about well I'm fine discussing
that but yeah I don't have the loom yet
I have the one that will tell us oh it's
starting to rain somebody was asking
about Seasons earlier
yeah
we're in
you can see what uh what they're
starting to put up here
oh level two lock
oh dude
let's go
[Music]
all right so clearly whatever I changed
was not the right the special items is
not what I thought it was so
let's see it was
where did it go
it was something like special
notifications there we're gonna turn it
back on
no I haven't seen Christmas yet
have not seen Christmas yet your level
13 still don't have access to skill
points
uh just just keep playing
just keep playing
yeah you you get a lot though when you
first open them up yeah yeah
closing shop yet yeah that's just where
we went we just went into uh Glad Rags
there
just went into
oh wait revelio
hold on hold on I heard one
there it is I love these things man
Savvy traveler knows that some water
wells may have more to offer than this
relatively innocuous water well in the
village of hogsmead
nice
[Music]
all right so
let's go and take a little peek at
Hogwarts
let's take a little peek at Hogwarts
because we haven't done that yet
we haven't done that yet on the whole
stream
all right so if you go to Hogwarts map
right here
so it's kind of interesting the way the
Hogwarts map works like if you want to
access one of the flu Flames here which
I'm just gonna I want you guys to
experience Hogwarts A lot of it for
yourself
so we'll probably just do like I'll just
show you like the great hall or
something like something really iconic
that we've already seen a little bit of
here
let's start in the we'll start in the
viaduct Courtyard
so just think about all for those of you
who have been here watching tonight or
those of you go back and see it on the
replay think about everything you've
seen so far
and then when we go inside Hogwarts here
just realized that that was like that
was here this whole time like
we could have just what in the world
okay the first time I saw something
happening like this I thought it was a
glitch or bug
no the feet give it away it's definitely
not it's definitely not
and so now here we go getting
sidetracked in Hogwarts as well
what what is this
is somebody gonna help her or is this
okay it's just normal all right it's
just normal I guess it's a normal
occurrence
gotta someone's shooting off fireworks
over here
the little werewolf statue
all right all right we're going to the
castle I promise
hey Florida candy I know right
everything we've been doing and
exploring tonight and then oh by the way
dude is this a revelio
oh didn't even know this was here
37 out of 50 right now
take on all challenges
if I can find any oh synovia
oh she's just you oh wait thank you
again for finding my cops you're welcome
I'm I never could have done it myself I
already did this side quest work
yeah Bean this is uh this is PS5
performance mode
okay that was cool that was cool one of
the things I talked about in my
impression early Impressions is like
some of the dialogue and some of the
random NPCs like you just won't you just
won't get much from them
that was cool though that she remembered
something I had done and I didn't even
have to walk up and there was no prompts
like she just she just talked about it
that was pretty cool
oh yeah we should show it in Fidelity
that's a good uh
we'll wait till we get into the
dude with the books here
just letting everybody take it in right
now take it in
the music is something that I'm still
I'm trying to figure out like what
exactly triggers when the music plays
it's like sometimes you're walking
through Hogwarts
and it's just music like left and right
and then other times it's just quiet
like this
I saw that
I saw that
oh
reward full of hexes your father's
instant mongos to get his horns removed
and it's taken the house elf a week to
unstick that screaming portrait awake
you will behave also help me Merlin I
will bring you so help me Merlin
okay that's the first time I've seen
that happen in the Great Hall
oh my gosh
that was too funny
yeah time of day I wondered about that
too like if it at certain times of day
whoa did that just
look like something just changed on
there
yeah so we're in the great hall now
poor guy I know right I am uh I'm
Gryffindor Gryffindor
despite the look I let my eight dude
they're being really quiet in here right
now must be early morning I've been in
here before and you just like you hear
the chatter
you hear like it's like a more it's like
a loud chatter of students
and see there's the music
I like it better with music
I think it's just
just the vibe man just the vibe
lets you guys figure out how to
how to open that one on your own
so here nice look at the grand staircase
can you jump
watch this Mr cold
watch this
you can indeed
you can indeed jump
you guys recognize that
which passage oh yeah
oh yeah yes I told you you're very
clever clever what how offensive
that's fine a genius
but I'll allow your limp vocabulary is
that a ghost the solution charm is
superb disillusioned still here's a
dummy guys it's like what the heck
stupid
if you'd look where you're going instead
of barging about
oh my gosh I'm just trying to
Invisibles no that's not stop it you'll
make it success oh you're right you made
the book disappear you blithering Moon
mind that's my essay for sure abandoned
potions of the Middle Ages as compared
to the black plague no the one on
invisibility
what is happening
this must be like one of those wow
moments they talked about like with peas
just these random things that happen
around the castle Duncan knows his
reputation to you
that's a reference to me oh I'm not I'm
not gonna talk to this guy yet
but when you guys meet him when you play
something cool something cool with him
okay watch this watch this
do you see the house self
if you if you find a house elf in the
castle
they will immediately disappear
oh dude wait
oh he's he's looking for his
oh my gosh okay that's good
that's good he's looking for the page
now
and we got peeves somewhere
where are you at peeves
where is he at
pet cat oh yeah I forget there's some
new people and we we pet the cat earlier
oh it's called there it is there it is
there it is
they're all over the castle
and thankfully not like Mrs Norris
not like Mrs Norris
and there we go
oh dude peas was just here
that's the little thing that he uh oh
is that Nick
there he goes yeah that happens all the
time just be wandering around
looks like the gray lady right there
oh that's so cool man
yeah so this must have been where peas
was
oh
whoops
whoops sorry about that
welcome guys thank you for the new
follows
hello there
looking a bit scruffy today aren't we oh
am I am I
all right so I'm kind of I don't know if
I wanna I don't want to spoil this for
the fellow gryffindors I mean yes
they've already showed the common room
but the um your first time in the common
room is really fun it's really fun guys
I think you should experience it for
yourself the password as far as I I
think you only have to do it the first
time
I think you only have to do the password
the first time
PC waiting room hello there
what happens if you try to enter other
common rooms Supernova with the Super
Chat great question so I have went to
both the Slytherin
and
Hufflepuff
and could not get in
could not get in and I tried
I tried like Slytherin you just I was
standing right there you can see where
the snake like is supposed to be
but I couldn't get in I haven't found a
way yet to do it I haven't found a way
yet to do it I don't know if there's
like poly juice or something where your
pop's possibly going to be able to
all right you know what we'll put it
we'll put it to the chat
we will put it
to
the chat on if you guys want to see
show Gryffindor common room yes or no
and we're not going to keep it up long
show Gryffindor
common room
uh I don't think all of the paintings
move as I'm looking at all these right
here though yes like I've seen all of
these movies
oh sorry I'm gonna have to go back
aren't I all right ask your community
all right let's see let's see what the
if you want to see it yes or no
vote in the poll there in the poll
oh my gosh yes it's totally gonna win
yes it's totally gonna win
all right so if you're in oh maybe not
Maybe not maybe not
it's at 115 votes right now when we get
to 200 I'm going to stop it
or maybe 150.
Maybe 150.
oh yes somebody asked about the mask
earlier yeah yeah sorry sorry
so whenever you're looking at the gear
like don't go by this you have to go by
the appearance so this is the one right
here duelist's mask is what it's called
a mask for the formidable duelist earned
by defeating enemies in the battle
arenas
there you go all right we yeah we we
crossed 150.
87 percent
all right so if you guys don't want to
see the Gryffindor common room you can
go ahead and hop out now I'll give you a
second here give you a second here to
hop out if you don't want to see it oh
you put your hood on by going right here
you hover on the cloak and then triangle
hood on and off
you know what let's take let's look a
little bit respectable as we go into the
common room
let's go ahead and take off our cloak
and guys if you're heading out we will
be live tomorrow morning on Twitch
at 10 A.M
all right
oh I've never seen this happen
ing it's night now so that's why there's
new students here
oh this is so cool
oh dude Nick's over here just pacing I
have yet to figure out what this is
I've yet to figure it out house chest
and place like don't know don't want to
know we'll figure it out
all right so Nick just floating around
in there
all right so this is like the main area
of course
yeah it's just twitch.tv slash retro
raconteur
see I feel like
I feel like there should be music all
the time
at least a little bit you know
here's that chudley cannons poster so
what it actually said all this time that
we were wondering heading or 21.
heading for 21.
because like I want I want the music
what are you up to now one of the best
one of the coolest parts of oh we could
do this
so I showed in the preview event we did
not really love this mini game but now
I don't know if they tweaked something
but
I figured them out very quick now so if
you if you don't like it the first time
stick with it and they're just like
they're gonna become second nature
they will become second nature
yeah I feel like we need music right now
like while you're in
while you're in the Gryffindor common
room or really while you're in the
castle
but I don't know I'm curious I'm curious
what you guys think like do you feel
like there should always be
music playing when you're in the castle
I feel like it adds a little bit to it
let's see oh level two we can't do that
one
we can't do that one
all right let's show one more room wait
is there no one in here there's no one
in their beds
no one is in the bed
where is everyone
ambient music option and volume control
students are gone
students out of bed
yeah see I don't even know what time it
is
in the game
this area right here is pretty cool this
we saw this in the uh
yeah I just like hold on this doesn't
feel right to me man let's go wait
and let's change it to uh I think it's
gonna go today oh there we go
see if it takes a second oh there's
people in there
yeah we they need they need to add
and again maybe that maybe that's
something that's going to be in the
patch oh my goodness my lights just went
out I forgot those are on a timer
yeah I talked about this briefly in my
impressions
I don't know if it's a bug or not when
it comes to the
when it comes to the music
like sometimes you're wandering around
the music's like it's just great it's
playing it's awesome and then other
times it's like oh wait it's really
quiet
it's really very quiet
so I don't know
revelio
yeah I definitely feel like it should be
playing
reports of students Vanishing at night
hopefully oh
there it went
now tell me this doesn't feel so much
better now
so much better
oh yeah someone was asking about
performance versus uh let's show that
really quick
so we'll switch it over to Fidelity
hopefully this doesn't crash the Stream
all right so now we are out of oh yeah I
can tell right away
I prefer smooth though I prefer smooth
it looks better
like when you're just standing here
looking around it looks a lot better but
then when you start to move
you're going to get the the 30 30 FPS
then
so Ray tracing is coming in the day one
patch even though it's there I don't
know if it's working yet okay so this is
my room
because that's my spot right there
yeah oh my gosh it's making me like it's
actually making me sick
I'm actually getting a little bit motion
sick which if you if it's it definitely
looks better it looks better but man
like I'm so used to higher frame rates
now
it's hard it's hard for me to do now the
balance mode if you have a vrr display
the balance mode is really good too
because it's um well I mean it's like a
balance between oh my gosh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah so much better
so much better
I know the frames right you put it in
there
all right man guys I'm about to fall
over dude it's 12 30 my time
those of you on the PC hold strong hold
strong not much longer to go
uh thank you all so much for being here
this has been this has been a blast
despite the rocky start and the stream
not working properly
um for all the newcomers I know there
were a lot of new people here tonight
thank you all for being here we stream
um well
the game's out now I used to say every
Tuesday we do two uh Tuesday night
stream on YouTube but now
um if you're if you're not in the
Discord exclamation point Discord you
can also follow me on Twitter at retro
wrecking tour we've got a Full Slate of
streams coming up this week we had
planned to do everything YouTube but
they're doing some drops Avalanche is
doing some drops tomorrow on Twitch so
we're gonna be on Twitch tomorrow
back on YouTube Thursday and then
probably twitch again
wait wait it's Monday
so Tuesday we're on Twitch Wednesday
YouTube and then Thursday probably back
to Twitch again
foreign
they are drops for
um
items in the game cosmetic items one of
them is a Merlin cloak which looks
awesome that one you have to be watching
the official Avalanche stream
Jake it's saying release three nine if
it's saying release four nine then
you're on like the PS4 you're looking at
the PS4 version
12 and a half hours Patrick still here
oh my goodness Patrick
your Trooper man a trooper guys thank
you all so much for being here tonight
all the insane insane donations we had
to start stream
and then how many people we had in here
for most of the night hope you guys had
a blast this is just the beginning we're
gonna be doing a lot of streaming this
week hope to see you there
as always thank you all so much for
watching
I'll talk to you again soon